Hello Ladies and gentlemen,
we're here with Lisa [inaudible] and Joe
Diaz.
My name's Joe Rogan and I host a podcast
called the experience.
Dude.
Uh,
this poster you just brought me in,
Joey Diaz was just brought me in one of
the dopest fucking things I've ever seen
in my life.
It is a,
a poster with Leonard scattered and the
rolling stones.
And we were talking about this on the
way in here.
Knebworth festival from 1976 America's
confederate rockers,
Leonard Skinner.
And then underneath it it says along
with the best rock and roll band in the
world,
Britain zone,
rolling stones.
Who is kind of weird cause you've got
one band that's the headliner there,
the biggest picture.
And then it says the other bands,
the best band in the world.
No.
Okay.
Oh,
hi.
Oh wait,
no,
no.
They had no fucking idea this but power
that these guys were bringing over that
bill on the road,
opening up the ted.
Ted was a powerhouse and 76 Ted
nugent's.
Oh,
cat scratch fever,
you know,
freefall.
Yeah,
cat scratch fever and then the live out
can go home.
Stranglehold.
Nobody was messing with.
Dave was hunting.
He was eating what he haunted.
Nobody in heard these things.
He was hunting with some shitty ass
equipment too.
They had like old school archery bows
back then like recurves and like real
shitty compound bows.
Did he have like the whole compound then
with like the animals and like the
family has had property in Michigan for,
he's got a couple of places.
He's got one place in Florida and he's
got one place in Michigan and they're
both like these gigantic private hunting
grounds.
He just took,
he didn't do any coke.
He just took all his money and he bought
a,
you know,
just a giant chunk of land and then he's
got one in Texas now.
No booze,
no cigarettes,
no nothing.
You could do any of that.
He doesn't have no worry at all.
No,
no,
no.
I think he drinks a little one.
He's fucking crazy.
But it's like when those guys tried to
debate him,
like do you ever see a ted nugent versus
a Pierce Morgan?
No.
On gun control?
He led them up like a Christmas tree
because Pierce Morgan didn't have all
piers Morgan is like,
you know,
he,
he's a proper sounding British guy.
But like when it gets to the fucking red
line,
when it gets the red line of arguments,
he falls apart.
Like Ben Shapiro ate him up and Ted
nugent ate him up.
A lot of the conservative guys that are
like really slick,
smooth talkers,
they can eat them up when they get into
the really like the high revs of the
conversation because he didn't
understand that a lot of the gun deaths
is also bad guys that are shot by guns.
Like people that are shot by cops.
Like all that stuff is sort of
calculated it in like he didn't
understand,
he didn't have all those facts in order.
So you,
if you're arguing with a guy like Nugen
who does these kind of arguments with
people like gun control arguments,
he's got like his words down to a tee.
He's done a couple of these.
Did one of them in a gun store?
They were in a gun store.
Yeah,
sure.
Go ahead please on it.
It's hilarious.
I'm not rock and roll stage.
I just saw sang a song about waist deep.
I mean,
you gotta be kidding me on a rocky.
Do you ever see Richard Pryor life?
I want Sam kinison.
How about Lenny Bruce?
I one of them.
Get over it.
That's some funny for a man who is a,
who is a patriot,
who purports to love his country.
That was quite shocking.
Disrespecting me.
Put it in a official CNN.
Piers Morgan.
Yes.
Anybody that wants to disarm me can drop
dead.
Anybody that wants to make the unarmed
and helpless people that want to
literally create the proven places were
more innocence or killed called gun free
zones.
We're going to beat you there.
No vote you out of office or suck on my
machine is,
but you can take it,
whichever is,
I'd love to suck on your machine gun.
The whole point,
the whole point of your defense is that
a lot of people do drop dead precisely
because you are armed to the teeth.
You like everybody else to be not true.
Write this down.
See your soul.
You write this stuff.
80 people a day die in America from gun
shows,
75 of them to 78 of them statistics by
the uniform crime report by the FBI and
the UN and the UN study on violent
crime.
78 of those 80 are let out of their
cages by corrupt judges and prosecutors
who know the recidivism,
exotic control,
no that the commit the crimes again and
they let them walk through plea
bargaining,
early release and program.
They still just my ass.
Where you have the most firearms
citizens in America,
you have and lowest violent crime rate
where you have the hi the worst gun
control.
You had the highest crime rate peers
choose one.
Do you want a lot of crime?
We have it.
Gun Free Zones.
You want less crime?
We have that more people with concealed
weapons permit.
Why do you guys resists that?
Statistic is a you guys,
you guys are nuts.
You're playing the devil's advocate and
I can play any advocate.
I like my side job,
right?
You're playing the idiots advocates.
More guns equals less crime.
You'll area let me,
unless I'm wrong and not doing well,
the couch,
be sure to let you know acid at this
point if you don't mind.
Um,
and there's something wrong with your
argument,
but you'll basically saying that 90% of
the gun crime comes from people let
other 96%.
Right,
but they still have to get access to
firearms.
If you had your way,
they would be 10 times as many firearms,
right?
Not True.
Or you want everyone in America to want
to go?
Not at all.
I've never said,
I got to tell you what is your position
and I hope you don't edit this out.
Whenever I've done interviews with guys
that are inclined to be anti gun,
they always go,
well,
I knew you wants everybody to have a
machine gun nugent.
Watch all the dear dad,
what does Nugeo not even close.
You want,
what I want is the second amendment.
We the people free individuals to have
the right to keep and bear arms for self
defense.
Find Fault with that.
Some down.
It's too good at that shit.
Did the,
the argument is just too weird.
It's just a weird argument.
I see both sides of it.
If nobody had guns,
if there's no guns,
nobody getting shot.
But I think people would be like my
shitty and people more and shit.
They do something,
they do something.
So they're your,
they're saying 75 out of 80 gun deaths
or criminals and bad people.
I don't know what the real numbers are,
you know,
but that's what he was saying in that
argument.
He was saying something along those
lines.
Yeah.
The people that guide,
when we talk about people that dine gun
deaths,
a lot of the people that die in gun
deaths are cons.
Ex Cons.
People out of jail,
people have already committed violent
crimes in her life,
which makes sense.
Most of the violence shit's going to be
happening by people with a history of
violence.
Well,
it's crazy.
The penalty you get for like,
uh,
ex felon with a gun,
like Gucci Mane just get out after two
years is I like,
I had been in print,
like you can go to prison for like seven
years.
Like there's a guy who said he's Prince,
his son,
he's in prison for seven years and he
had,
it was a felon in possession of a
handgun.
Let me ask you this,
when it's a guy like Gucci Mane,
who's a big time public character,
right?
He's a famous guy,
Cause ice cream tattooed on his face.
He's fucking crazy.
Right?
When a guy like Gucci gets caught for
something like that,
do you think they make an example out of
him?
They do you think that they take that
guy?
Yeah.
You already have that law to whatever
law that if you get caught with a
firearm,
you do two years just period period.
I don't know exactly what the parameters
of the law,
the Brady law as something you do two
years,
you don't even go to court.
It's two years automatically if you get
caught with a gun without a permit.
I don't know exactly the parameters.
Uh,
you know,
does that keep people from doing crimes?
What's that?
That two years that carrying a gun for
two years in New York?
Yes and no.
Right?
Some people carry a gun and all of a
sudden they go,
you know what?
I'm not going to say what I do for a
living,
whatever.
I don't know.
I,
you know,
it's like a,
you're saying Gucci Man Right now.
He's a high profile guy.
You know,
you're out at night.
You see some crazy shit at night.
There's times I'm driving after one.
I'm like,
I should've carried a fucking gun
tonight.
You know,
just in case.
Just in case you never know.
I don't know if,
look,
we were just talking about when you came
in about Denver and taxes,
like the make my day law.
I know people have moved to Colorado for
that law.
You know what that Youtube,
did you ever see,
you ever see the video of Sonny Liston
pulling a gun?
Ever seen that before?
Never before.
No.
What?
I mean,
40 only told me about it.
Yeah.
Hinchcliffe told me.
Yeah,
we were at the ice house and I was like,
you gotta be kidding me.
There's a video of this play that play
both of them.
Not one that maybe we can just place.
I want to hear the redneck.
He was apparently like screaming shit at
Ali everywhere he went and Sonny Liston
was just tired of this bullshit.
The whole situation finally came a head
and clay approach listing at the desert
in Las Vegas where the champ was
shooting craps and lanes and he got up
with Liston was in no mood to be
harangued by the mouth from the south
drawing the gun.
Sunny fires frightened who's young
tormentor into a hasty retreat.
The gun was filled with blanks.
Holy.
Come on son.
That is one of the craziest things ever
going to see in your life.
Who pulled a gun out on Ali
in the middle of the casino,
shot at in the air and then said,
look,
it's just blanks.
No big deal.
Wanting to go back to his crap game
like,
dude,
what kind of environment that that dude
grow up in?
I used to know a lot of people never
carry fucking startup pissed has his
shit and the 70s just to get the father
would carry those type of pistols cause
you never know.
But what happens if the other guy has a
real one venue,
then you're fucked.
You're fucked,
But that sonny liston thing was so
crazy,
first of all,
how casually he did that.
He did so casually,
and then how he shot his jacket to let
everybody knows just blanks.
Like,
come on,
relax.
Like no big deal.
Let's just go back to the game.
Right?
Like he just went back to the game.
He didn't go.
I gotta get the Fuck Outta here right
now for TMZ shows up dog.
And let me say something.
They'll be runs quicker when they hear
gunshots to black people,
they fucking,
they react,
they react.
Exactly.
Know what time it is and they have
fucking that shit look on.
He just shoots it in the end.
They all run out.
It just shows you like,
I'll leave.
It's so crazy.
But then Denali should have gone at
frazier in Africa,
titty,
somebody shot somebody in Africa,
not shot,
but pulled up to the hotel with have got
an Africa.
Whether it was a foreman or Frasier,
somebody.
When holly was in his hotel room,
they went over.
It was frazier.
What is that phrase?
You went over there with a gun and
pointed it up at the building and shit.
Either or or something crazy like,
God,
these are just pulling guns on each
other back.
People aren't ready for Ali in the 60s
when he's not playing with you have like
that.
They just weren't ready for him.
He would just look at him.
He's still tormenting him.
A casino.
Super metal number.
The casino megaphone out of the bus
window.
Yeah,
exactly.
And that was in front of his house.
You pulled up on his lawn?
Yeah,
he told him,
man,
that's what he was doing.
The bus.
They'd like champ that bad in the world
or something crazy.
I know.
Like I'm telling you,
man.
I think Mcgregor takes it to a very high
level,
but you got to go back and look at the
old Ali stuff.
Maybe sometimes I forgot how good it was
because nobody had been like that before
him.
He showed up at the gorilla face.
Joe Frazier,
what does it say?
The most colorful fighter?
World's most colorful.
Cassius clay.
The world's most colorful,
and this was back
before he'd even change his name,
Cassius clay.
Wow.
It's crazy,
man.
It's crazy that that was in our parent's
lifetime and it seems like a different
world when your parents left them.
I'm an old man though,
before Asia.
I do remember being a little kid going
home to living in New York City.
What year was that?
What year was I'm Sonny Liston.
I want to say that was when I was a
baby.
Like I was 67 like it's 1967 or
something.
I don't know.
When did you win the title?
What year was it when he beats all he
listing?
Yeah,
I'll slightly,
it was fucking crazy.
They didn't even know how old he really
was.
No,
no one knew how fucking 90 30.
It's like a Cuban dude.
Their first fight was in 64 seconds.
65 64.
So I wasn't even born yet.
So it was three years before I was born.
And um,
that was a different world,
man.
It's a different world.
You watching that video,
you're like,
wow.
Like America was just a different place.
So when Cassius clay was fighting,
all of the country would just stop.
Like everyone went in everywhere would
just watch the fight.
Well,
I remember when I was a kid,
I was um,
living in San Francisco and my parents
went,
we went way out of our way to make sure
that we watch tv because Sonny Liston
and Muhammad Ali,
and not sounding less than I'm Leon
spinks in Muhammad Ali were having the
rematch and the rematch was a big thing
to everybody because Muhammad Ali was
such a hero.
He was so much more than just a fighter.
Especially then because he had gone over
the three years,
have not fought because he didn't want
to go to Vietnam.
What year was that,
Leon to and Mama Alley is in the early
seventies,
I want to say.
Um,
well,
you got to have no teeth.
Yeah.
Leon had no team.
Michael was the one that fought Tyson.
Tyson knocked on Atlantic city.
Yes.
Right.
That's Mike Spence.
Michael spinks was the,
the genx.
He was the former light heavyweight
champion.
He was a light heavyweight champ for
many years.
He's a really good light,
heavy weight,
really good boxer,
very smart and beat Larry Holmes for the
heavyweight title.
But it really wasn't a heavyweight.
You know,
he'd be Larry Holmes.
Larry Holmes couldn't pull the trigger
anymore.
And you know,
Michael just was real slick,
real smart.
It wasn't dangerous enough to like
threaten homes,
like to try to knock them out.
But Larry just didn't have it in the
tank like he did later in life.
It was a controversial decision anyway.
But anyway,
beat Larry.
And so he became the champ.
I guess it was like Ibf champ or
something like that.
I don't even remember.
And then Tyson just marked them,
merck them.
Oh,
it was awful.
That's the difference between a real
heavyweight and a light heavyweight.
Like there's just a difference in frame.
Like nobody had ever done that to
Michael spinks.
Michael spinks was so good.
He had a nasty right hand dude.
He was fucking dudes up at light
heavyweight,
but he was also had,
had a long career,
fought a lot of really tough guys and
then,
you know,
gets uh,
gets the money fight the night that he,
that Tyson knock the mountain record
time.
Yeah.
I was never so pissed off.
My wife is robbing a drug dealer and he
will left the house to go to watch the
fight at somebodies house.
So here I am,
case in the fucking joint.
He leaves 10 minutes before the fight,
I'm still crawling through a window,
fight in the dog off and all of a sudden
I hear cars,
I get in my fucking car,
I got the coke.
Well,
often I see him coming back and he calls
me like,
and that way if somebody robbed my
house,
but he talking about Nah,
I went,
I came back early because he knocked
them on 13 seconds,
15 seconds.
What the fuck?
I'm never in Boulder,
Colorado on Macarthur Lane.
I was casing the motherfuck out.
Those are the days where,
do you remember the p?
The closed circuit days?
Yeah.
We used to watch fights at movie
theaters.
Really?
Yeah,
it was a big thing.
Yeah.
You get,
your friends would get together and we
would go,
we'd all go to a movie theater and we'd
watch a fight on like closed circuit or
they even have it at the Boston Garden.
I used to go to the track.
Oh yeah.
In the metal lands and that's why I saw
you,
boy,
the Detroit hip man,
Tommy hearns fight some,
but like a great fight.
Like,
I don't know if it was Duran or Leonard
Duran,
he murked around,
but he fought somebody and we watched it
on a track on a Monday night.
Do you ever see that knock out that
hearns have you seen it reasonably and
pull that up?
Tommy hearns man was such a freak of
nature because he was so tall and long
man.
And he had muscle,
like it wasn't just tall and long.
He was tall and long.
Buddy was fucking strong and if he
caught you at the end of that right
hand,
I mean it was one of the most
devastating punches and all boxing,
which is why it was so crazy that hacker
was able to just walk right through
them.
Haggler just walked right through him,
man.
Yeah.
Hagler you could just take it like
nobody else.
I mean haggler had to like nasty power,
but one of the things that was most
impressive about Hagler was you could
just hit him with anything.
They never seem to be here.
Oh yeah.
Ryan had a great fight.
Maybe four.
That was a great,
great,
great fucking fight.
Haggler really respected Duran in that
fight and really didn't take it to him.
He knew how dangerous Duran was.
Duran was a still a real sneaky boxers
this after you'd beaten Davey Moore,
but see her and just had this distance
man,
and he could fuck Duran up at distance.
He would just like come in with that
whip of a punch cod.
Damn Dude.
They don't even look like then the same
way.
Cool.
Ooh,
there's a right hand that drop some,
Oh shit.
They really weren't.
Duran started off his career as a 135
pounder,
then moved up to one 47 and I don't know
what the fight this fight was probably
one 54 if I had to guess.
[inaudible] would,
uh,
this fight was at what?
Weight class?
Because he fought as high as
middleweight.
We fought Hagler who was at
middleweight?
He was fighting guys at some pretty
heavy weights.
One 54 yeah.
So that's light,
light metal
or super welterweight depending on what
organization calls it.
But yeah,
there Duran was like 20 pounds over.
His ideal fighting weight is ideal.
Fighting way.
It was lightweight.
It wasn't a big framed guy like these
guys,
but he still was skillful enough to hang
in with them for the most part.
But hearns Merck.
Yeah,
it is right there as the MERC shot.
Yeah.
That's one they don't even count for.
When you get hit like that,
they don't even bother counting.
Let me ask you something.
How do you feel about guns right now?
This
point in your life with a family and
what's going on in your mind?
How do you feel about guns?
This is the real problem with guns.
The same problem with everything else.
People are fucking stupid.
They're a bunch of people that are
fucking stupid.
Now,
if you had to ask me,
do I think that everybody in this room,
do I think that they are responsible
enough to handle a firearm and own a
firearm?
Yes,
absolutely.
Everybody in this room is,
I believe so,
but is it everybody in the world?
Fuck no,
but it cou can decide.
Well,
that's the part in the whole law.
The whole point of the law is you can't
let some Thai ironical dictator decide
who can and can't be armed.
Because at the end of the day,
what we really have to worry about as
much as crime.
So you have to worry about the
government turning into crime because
the governments of,
of nations all over the world have
fucked the people over and done shit
that people don't want,
imprisoned them,
enslaved them.
And,
but when we supposed to ignore that and
we supposed to pretend we're passed that
we're passed that completely,
people never be like that again.
An armed militia is be in the
possibility that it all goes wrong.
That's what it's for.
It's not,
it's not for when everything's going
right.
It's for when it all goes wrong.
To deny the possibility that it could
all go wrong to me.
You're lying.
You're pretending we're better than we
are because you look all over the world.
There's war everywhere.
There's war everywhere in the world.
There's murder everywhere in the world
is robbery and thievery.
Everywhere in the world.
There's not equal.
It's not equal with,
as the amount of chances people have is
not equal.
The amount of,
uh,
the time you do in jail if you get
caught for things,
there's all sorts of inequalities and
all sorts of real fucking problems in
the world.
And to deny,
to say that we've reached some utopian
place,
we don't have to worry about the
government turning into a tyranny
bullshit.
No,
I don't think it's,
I don't think the government right now
is a tyranny.
I don't think they're controlling you.
That's,
I don't think they're doing anything
unbelievably oppressive.
I think they respond to it in a certain
extent to the amount of pressure that
people put on them.
And when people say things like that,
we don't want to go into Syria.
Remember that Syria thing or Obama was
on TV.
We were like,
fuck this.
No one wants to go to Syria.
They like,
what did the dit,
dit,
dit to ease back on the Syria.
He's back on Syria.
At
the end of the day,
people that are used to going to war,
liked to go to war.
They make a lot of fucking money doing
it.
And you have to be aware of that kind of
shit.
You gotta be aware of people trying to
force you into things.
The other thing about Kent State,
man,
that was in our lifetime,
you know the,
during the Vietnam War,
they fucking shot kids that were
protesting the shot him on the college
campus for doing nothing but protesting.
That wasn't that long ago,
man.
It's not that long ago.
I'm not advocating.
That should be some fucking uprising and
people should pull guns.
But I'm,
I am saying you can't just have one
group of people running other groups of
people with no recourse with,
with no you,
you,
the,
the people don't have any ability to
stop them.
So the people in power,
we just have to trust that they're going
to be good.
That's crazy.
Why would you do that?
They're just people and people.
If you give them too much power,
they almost always fuck it.
The almost always abused the shit out of
it.
It's very rare that someone gets in a
position of power and all of a sudden
does wonderful selfless things for the
world.
Bullshit.
They do weird things.
They have weird fucking people that get
paid off of subsidies for like oil and
corn and greasy dealings with private
prisons.
Like there's a lot of fucking weird shit
going on and power.
So to say that we're just,
oh,
everything's gonna be fine.
We don't need guns in him.
In England we didn't have guns and we
find you still a queen.
You still in some weird fucking quasi
imperial state.
The scariest thing though is like if you
go on facebook and you scroll through
this video after video of people fight,
like that's the biggest thing that was
worldstar orange people fighting.
Well that's only hears me for all these
people to have guns like it.
That's true too.
But to be honest,
like with all the road rage happening,
like that guy a few months ago,
it got pulled out of his car.
I'm like Hollywood boulevard.
Some fucking gun took up to be on the
offensive.
I don't want a gun to be on the
Right.
I want a gun and case.
Last night him and I were talking shit
to pull 30th bet on my side street.
Three cops with three,
uh,
a guy kept circling God,
you know,
after half hour cop came by because
somebody actually called the problem
with competencies is two guys standing
out there.
Ah,
bullshit.
Look at you and criminal looking
motherfucker.
We were out there just telling stories
that till the commies.
Yeah,
I know
for a minute.
Then when that white car came around the
second time,
I thought I needed a gun.
I don't know what people are thinking.
No,
you don't know what people are thinking.
You could zig when you could have zagged
and you could run into someone who's out
of their fucking monitor and fucking
once and you never know.
I mean,
I'm not an advocate of being armed all
the time.
That's not what I'm saying.
What I'm saying is you can't let the
government tell you whether or not you
can have a weapon.
It's just not.
It doesn't make sense.
For years,
I had the felony.
I still have the felonies and the
government tells me I can't have a
pistol.
Now.
Mike crime was with a pistol.
All right.
They go off.
No,
but there was a potential for violence.
There's always a,
always a potential for violence in my
heart and in my mind.
I did a probationary period already.
That was a 19 987 I did a probationary
period.
Again,
more in the probationary period.
I feel in my heart right now,
I'm capable of carrying a gun.
As much as I hate it,
I fucking hate those things because I
know what they bring.
You know what I'm saying?
I know what they bring to some people
and I got to bring it to me cause I'm
not young and stupid anymore.
Do you understand me?
I really wanted to protect my daughter.
I really wanted to.
There's weird people doing every time
you watched the news,
every time I watch the news and I see
something stupid.
What happened in Houston yesterday?
You see that?
Yes.
No.
So what happens?
Soldiers snapped.
No four fucking tours in Afghanistan and
he got some fucking machine gun.
He shot somebody at a gas station.
There was so many fucking bullets that
the gas station blow up in a suburban
install.
The cops were in this,
you got to see the cop cars.
It was like heat.
Remember those cars with the windshields
and shit.
So do not get in a road rage with
somebody.
No,
no,
no.
He just wanted to go guest as you shot a
customer and from there the party
started,
walked down the street shooting a one
dead six engine,
you know,
shot up 30 fucking cause in the middle
of the street.
I'm walking into a movie with my
daughter.
I'm minding my business instead of
fucking driving.
Let's walk through the Taco place today.
That could happen.
I know this going in when I leave my
house every morning,
I know this is possible and that's the
messed up part because he has a gun,
he has the right to have a gun.
But if someone else in Houston,
they come up,
shot dead,
six injured randomly.
Just that whoever you need that in your
life.
Now I'm not a sharp shooter.
Black could shoot him in the fucking
leg.
I believe in shooting them in the leg.
If I have a great cover,
I'm not looking to shoot the fucking guy
like the cops are gonna.
I mean you should have heard the tapes.
It's crazy.
Mass Texas to where everybody's armed.
But you know,
many people are not trained.
That's also big part of a brother.
Let me tell you something.
You have no idea what happens to your
body when you hear a gunshot 10 feet
from me.
Oh yeah,
you have no idea.
I don't know.
I don't give a fuck what they won't want
to try for chocolate though.
And I know,
I know he knocked the fuck out of you,
but you've never heard a gunshot go off.
You got to see people's faces to see
people's faces and you hear that clip
for real.
They ain't a movie.
The Saint,
no dogs no longer in movie or what's the
other guy that played the mechanic?
Ain't one of these movies.
This is [inaudible] stadium.
You know,
just shoot you.
It just kills you.
That's why people freeze.
Freeze.
You're going to shock people that are
not used to that.
They play Bingo and they take their
family for ice cream.
They don't need that shit.
Yeah,
I,
I'm petrified.
I live in theories of
this.
It always listen to this Ted podcast.
It was really interesting man.
And they were talking about a comradery
and they were talking about the people
that go to war together.
And one of the things that they all say
is that,
uh,
their comradery and their love for each
other is unlike any love or friendship
that anybody else could ever possibly
experience because it's so intense
because it's like life or death every
single day in that when the wars are
over and they're back home,
they're happy,
they're safe and they're with their
family and everything,
but they,
they look back and they go,
the best time of my life was being at
war.
Like tat.
That's crazy.
What does that say about people about,
and I'm not,
this is not a judgment,
I'm not like not a moral judgment.
What does that say about people?
What I'm saying is what does that say
about the way the brain works?
Like how strange is it that people can
get so excited about being in danger and
the comradery that comes from being in
danger?
It like reawakens us almost puts us in
this like primal state that we use to
exist in.
And now instead of that worst case
scenario,
some guy fucking snaps and he's on the
high,
he starts shooting at people.
That's the,
that's kind of like worst case scenario
that we all worry about.
But most people fucking keep it
together,
which is one of the most amazing things
about being a person.
But the experience is flat,
does not enough excitement.
There's not enough happening.
There's not enough stimulation is not
enough creativity.
So you live a different life,
you live a different life.
You guys are podcasts and then doing
standup shows.
So there's all this,
how this outpouring of creativity.
You have all this,
uh,
room for expression.
Some people that just feel like
compressed,
they feel like they've just,
they've got a board tied to their chest,
into their back,
and every day someone pulls the fucking
strap on that board and that's every
day.
And it's just boring as fuck.
And when they deploy and they're over
there and you know,
yeah,
they're gonna miss their family.
Yeah.
They're going to be risking their lives.
All the,
all those things are 100% true,
but for them,
that experience was the best time of
their life.
That's amazing.
We're strange.
No,
no,
no.
Because you and I work in an office
together.
You'll meet Jamie and lead work in an
office together.
We go on every Monday we talked about
the UFC and then,
and I will lay this back,
the fucking stocks and bonds or whatever
the fuck we're doing,
and then we call away on Friday and
that's it.
The same works for the people I did
crimes with early on.
I still talk to those people because I
went through a weird experience with
that.
Something that you don't do it.
Most people something that,
and they accepted me,
who I'm in front go on before and I,
I talked to this kid timmy,
I will every fucking day at five in the
morning we'd talk.
He was the getaway driver.
When I robbed the jewelry stuff,
I have a loyalty to him,
but we were at a light and the cops came
by and the trunk opened up with a gold
chains.
We both shut up pants.
It's,
you know,
it's something about that.
I always had the respect for the
camaraderie.
What gets you through those first six
years of comedy when your life is shit.
What the fuck gets you through it?
We'll get you through.
We were just talking about it right when
I call you.
When I go with driving to quincy tonight
motherfucker.
That way you just is dead always.
Shit.
How much older than I got like 11 bucks
Joey.
I know like fucking nine dog.
We got a steak.
We'll buy a bag of weed.
How much fun you don't want to like
that's the best part of comedy.
It's hard to believe,
right?
That's the batch part account.
I don't give a fuck what anybody tells
you.
Standing ovations.
Selling tickets.
Look.
Part of comedy you're going to remember
is when you were brody Stevens in the
car with Josh Wolfe and I got brody in
the back,
tied up in the fucking back in the Volvo
and I'm doing a hundred with his car and
he's yelling,
stop it.
Normal people do not live like this.
Every time I see droughty I give him a
hug because it's when I'm in that
fucking box on my mission to wherever
the fuck Buddha land.
That's what I'm going to be thinking
about.
How good of a time that I have when I
had $3 in my,
you ever read the brother Sam book,
brother Sam,
you know about Sam and Sam Kinison,
his brother Bill,
part of that fucking story.
The best part of that whole story that
every time I see call I give them a hug
because I can relate.
It's when they talked about how broke
they were and they would walk to the
comedy store,
they eat the fruit from the bar.
The bartender would chop up.
Wow.
Who admits that?
Who had mixed that?
But you and I know that secret.
And it's the same thing,
man.
Well,
this is a thing that this happened to
when you're going on those gigs where
you don't know if this is gonna be,
it's going to be successful,
not just the Gig,
but this has a career like you.
You're not like,
I'm a comic fucking,
I'm a comic.
They like,
am I pulling this off?
Like,
is this,
I got a Gig now and I'm trying,
I'm,
I'm out here.
You know,
it's like me and fitzsimmons would do
these gigs and we would both be like
barely should be talking to people on
stage.
Barely.
I mean,
we were rookies,
man,
we were fucking rookies.
And in Boston,
if you could string together 20 minutes,
they had so many rooms.
Everybody was working.
It was crazy.
What are you able to have fun during
that time?
Or was a yes.
Fucking great.
Unbelievable.
So fun.
But I was like terrified.
It wasn't going to work out.
Terrified that I was wasting my time.
I mean,
cause it was a big chance.
I quit everything.
I knew I'd been papers or something like
that.
I kept delivering papers,
but I quit teaching at Boston University
and I quit teaching classes.
I said,
I don't want to do it.
I said I don't want to half asset and
I'm not thinking about it the way I used
to think about it when I was teaching
before it was like it was a,
it was life.
I was teaching life and I was teaching,
well you know people kicking and
punching.
It was like as important as life.
It was everything.
I was thinking constantly about
techniques and movements and strategies
and constantly and so when I was
teaching people I wanted people to be as
into it as I was and if they weren't I
really wasn't into it that they were,
I I like,
I had a bunch of students that I took up
to like you know,
pretty good level,
like a,
you know,
below black belt but pretty good level
where they're getting really good and
starting to win tournaments.
It was really exciting.
I was doing all this,
like from the time I was like 19 to 21
and I'm so teaching and competing at the
same time.
And when I first started doing comedy,
I was really,
I realized right away I was like,
I got to quit.
I coulda quit everything.
I just got to do this.
So it was like,
it was such a fucking leap man.
Every Gig,
I was terrified.
I was like,
is this stupid thing I'm doing?
Look,
what am I retarded?
Why the fuck I think I'm funny?
One thing I can get people to pay me to
talk and I'd see the guys that were
doing and in town,
the guys that were making it,
and it was just like they feel,
they felt just out of reach,
just just out of reach.
So you never know,
you know?
And then you'd go and you'd do some Gig
in Maine and get heckled and eat dick.
He's fucking Obama stage.
And they'd go,
oh my God,
what else could I do if this doesn't
work out?
What else could I do?
Because there was nothing else you
wanted to do.
No,
I would go home at night after a bombing
and just cry and I'd circle.
They used to have just for the labs and
newspaper.
Yeah,
I remember that section.
It had all the clubs state by state,
Alabama,
and I would circle the clubs.
That's,
I'm going to show them some day
show that
Birmingham,
but I'm going to go to see,
I love the ground and,
and one day event.
And you're like,
wow.
But it's so weird that there's so many
things I'm alive.
You could pay for.
You can't pay for love and you can't pay
for Camaraderie.
Man.
There's something about a camaraderie,
a real camaraderie.
He didn't like.
Sometimes when you go to Jujitsu,
when this guy fucking design,
yet he taps you at the end.
You get up and you hug them.
You go,
man,
that was great.
You sweat my face.
Jesus Christ.
I could smell the cheeseburger from last
night.
And that's come out of it.
You can't pay for that.
But it's weird that,
listen,
if you're running with people everyday
and they got your back,
I can't imagine that camaraderie.
That's real.
Yeah.
So what about,
what were the comradery that we're
talking about that this makes you
understand like what the story about
these guys that want to go back?
You know like the movie hurt locker,
you know,
but that's what's different because that
guy was kind of addicted to Dis
disarming bombs,
right?
The dude,
the other one,
the Clint Eastwood one American sniper.
Oh right.
Goes back and she couldn't figure it
out.
Why do you keep going?
What the fuck did you won't shut the
fuck off because you won't shut the fuck
up.
And this kid,
I don't know what's going on.
Let me go over that.
At least kill people.
Because then you feel,
can you imagine Joe Rogan?
Like all your life you got thrown out of
school.
You know you're fucking your mechanic,
you'll laws,
but all of a sudden you realize you're
going take alive.
You have to think of that.
You would put yourself in that position
when you're 18 years old,
19 years old,
you're in Vietnam and you realize that
you're taking your first tour back to
the United States.
Now you finished your year,
but you survive the 11 that went over
this,
six of them laugh.
Then you survive and then reality in
God's eyes you got 18 kills.
Nobody knows that as like a 19 year old.
Now you go back to civilization
and you've got to get paid 10 bucks an
hour to change tires.
Why do you think for years I kept
selling coke because nothing really can
compare to that excitement,
excitement,
excitement of doing something and I'm
supposed to do,
I'm going to,
I'm going to go sit with my wife and
drink mint juleps with her fucking
family.
I could be killing motherfuckers right
now.
You know?
You know,
you know you get that rally that you get
a lot of love for doing that.
It's like you get love and respect from
the people that you work with for doing
your job correctly.
But then for manning up but then not
dead when you're stabbing them
motherfucking tickets got dog and how
strong your heart heart's.
And then our dad,
brother one,
it's like a shock when they get that
taste of blood,
those 18 the way that they should be
over there when the ways that they want
you when you were 18 but when you're 31
and tried to go in,
you already got beliefs and shit.
That's why I think your central nervous
system has already been set.
They can't get you to kill and forget,
but an 18 year old who rob,
she had blood free.
What's that marine say?
Semper fi.
Mighten Cuba's yet,
but their fleet.
I thought about that.
Can you imagine coming back here at 25
and now you've got to work at a bakery?
Couldn't imagine good luck.
1250 an hour and you get two weeks a
year of me and my all you're dreaming
about his fucking putting makeup on and
I treat with ropes with a machine gun
and a gun and knives a whole,
how much work do you think they'd put
into Red Justin guys,
those first reacclimating them back into
society after.
You don't want me to tell you the
problems we have.
We don't,
we can't do it effectively.
It's like a guy getting out of prison
after 20 years.
We haven't figured out a way to do it
effectively yet that there's no mishaps.
There's always gonna be a small
percentage for this guy in Houston.
Yesterday did four tours.
How old was he,
Jamie
for tours?
What the fuck are you going to do in
this?
The United States,
it's going to give you that unless you
go on stage.
Even that,
even that,
it's nothing in comparison.
You said earlier,
like how crazy our brains are.
It's crazy how different.
Like when I was 18 it was 2007 I got
just graduating high school,
so like Iraq and Afghanistan were blown
away.
It was right at that time and I had
friends who went over but might like
what you are saying is exciting.
What I would want to wait from that.
There's no part of one five
years old for toys.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Well you're a smart guy,
Lee.
No,
but they're smart people there.
There's like,
oh it's just people that are willing to
do the stuff that's more dangerous
because it feels better because it feels
like even though there's risk involved,
at least you feel charged up and alive.
There's a life of excitement versus a
life of,
you know,
why do you think people climb rocks?
They'd climb Brock's cause it's actually
enjoyable climbing a rock.
No,
they climb a rock cause it's fucking
scary and you don't know if you can make
it.
You pretty sure you're to make it.
But there's a real risk that you get a
fucking hand spasm and you use this fall
for a long time until you splatter on
the bottom.
When you watch someone crazy like Alex
honnold,
right?
The guy with no ropes,
it does it with no ropes.
We had them in the podcast is super nice
guy.
Real,
real interesting guy.
Lives out of a van,
just travels around in climbs rocks.
He's an adrenaline junkie kid.
The climbing of the Rock,
it's like,
I mean I guess it's Kinda cool to be up
high and it's sort of like a version of
hiking for him cause he can kind of make
it.
But what's really going on is you,
you recognize that you are on the edge
always.
And so even if you're not like your
adrenaline's not flying,
you're not freaking out,
you're heart's not pounding your
heightened focus.
Incense is keenly aware that you're
holding back a waterfall of adrenaline.
You're keeping it together.
And so you're,
a lot of times guys that are doing like
crazy shit,
like tight rope walking and stuff like
that.
They're,
they're sort of addicted to trying to
control
what is this guy doing jamie?
Oh is this part core or something?
Just something really scary here in
about two seconds.
Go hand in a handstand.
No,
it's not.
Uh Huh.
Oh my God.
Oh my God,
this guy did.
He jumped and then did a hand.
He's still doing it on the edge.
Oh.
Oh my.
Have you seen the videos?
I like the people on the hover boards.
Hover boarding on like the tops of
buildings.
Don might have freaked me out more than
the hoverboard cause it guy was upside
down and I watched my daughter do those
things.
They don't know what he's land.
Perfect.
Fuck man.
Jesus Christ.
What the fuck is going on in Russia?
What are they feeding these people then?
Radioactive pigs from Chernobyl goes.
Ain't Russians?
Russia.
You heard Russian?
I heard Russian.
Didn't you hear Russian sound?
Sounded the Russian sounds.
My hands are sweaty.
I'm assuming it was Russian and my being
racist.
It's not a race though.
Rush the owner's room reason rob
Washington isn't a racist because they
look like us.
Right?
I mean they're totally not regular white
people.
No.
What does it say?
Does it say it's Russian?
Yeah,
it is Russia.
See Jesus Christ just assumed.
I pretty sure I heard some Russian
sounds though.
Yeah,
we're,
we're crazy people crazy with the need.
The juiced up need for those things.
It's like,
how do you feel?
Don't you don't even like feel sad when
someone's a comic and then they quit and
then you see him kind of hanging around
in a comedy club and they come back and
hang around and I haven't done standup
at 10 years.
You believe that?
Yeah.
How to deal with the bullshit no more.
My family's getting raised correctly.
Okay,
that's fucking great.
I just listen man.
You're going to do things in life that
you don't like and you,
and you recognize it.
You move on in La.
How many people have we met?
How many people that'd be starved?
So how many people went to Montreal and
I had said a lot and all of a sudden you
don't see him no more.
You just what I'm saying?
And then one day you go to a town and
you got to facebook,
hey I had to come back cause my uncle
died and I'm doing the podcast and kind
of do a guest spot.
You're like,
nope,
nope.
I don't know who you are.
I mean I just don't know what's going on
in anymore.
The whole guest spot things are weird
thing,
you know?
It's weird.
It's weird to ask people to come on a
professional show if you're not a
professional.
Like I get it.
Like that's how people get better.
They do guest spots,
but that should be something that
somebody asks you for.
It's you know like would you like to do
a guest spot like that?
You know like check you out on stage in
front of 3000 people but to like ask to
do that.
Like cause we all know like some comics
that are weird,
they'll like show up at your shows and
asked to do guest spot.
I'm like God I didn't know you were here
tonight.
Yeah,
I'm just driving your backspace fucking
Ontario often young and you didn't know
I was here tonight.
You don't see my name out there.
I made a rule about two years ago.
I love comedians.
I know what it is to be a comic.
So I'll tell you what I do.
I know what it was like for me to
feature until he that $400 for rent and
want to say that you get a call the week
before it.
The headline is bringing a feature I
get,
so I made a deal.
I won't bring a lot of features,
but I'm not doing guest spots and the
word gets out.
It's so crazy.
The word really gets out when you don't
do guest spots,
people don't show up to your shows no
more.
That's interesting.
I don't want them.
Whereas before they were showing up and
you they want to hang out in the green
room and here's my philosophy on it.
If you're so funny,
you wouldn't be here.
Get,
go get onstage.
And you know people come to the green
rooms and they want to hang out and
that's great.
I love seeing my old friends and stuff,
but I'm working right now and you're not
working well,
not only that,
you don't have to be on that show.
Here's the thing,
like I,
when I was a kid and that was a starting
out,
I love going to shows.
I still love going to shows.
I don't have to be on stage to enjoy a
show.
So if I go to show,
then I'm like trying to get a guest spot
on.
Someone's showing don't even know that
person or barely know that person.
That's fucking weird.
I never did that.
I don't know anybody who did that.
None of us did that.
You either got asked or you just kept
working.
He kept doing shows that were at your
level until you got better.
That's just what everybody does.
Like this guest Bot thing,
like that is not how it works.
You can't just show up and get on in
front of a couple thousand people.
I didn't have two gigs the night I lied
to you because I knew you were going to
ask me to come over to the ice house,
but I know you're working.
Yeah,
but I don't care what else.
I don't want them disrupting.
Oh that's very kind of you.
But I sometimes I go to the ice house
and there's 18 guys up before you and I
go,
this isn't right.
This pool guy did a all with justice and
now motherfuckers are doing 20 in front
of me,
you know,
and I go up there and the weight he gets
mad at me because I noticed like the
feel when I get to the fucking club.
But I'm ready to go steams coming out of
my nose.
I got to eat two stars to calm me down.
I already ate,
I worked out,
I'm fired up.
I gotta wait two or three fucking comics
now the last 15 minutes I'm pacing back
there like a fucking animal,
you know,
I just want to get up there and do my
fucking thing and now I got to wait.
And it's not that,
it's just that some comedians come into
a room to ruin the show,
blow this fucking place up and they
really blow away.
When I get down Thursday you work with
the other two guys,
you get the niche,
you see who you're already working with.
And then some guy wants to come in
Saturday like,
oh my God,
I didn't know you went down because I do
it guest,
it's not going to happen.
Especially Saturday cause he got to show
you,
I've got two shows especially fucking
Friday.
And it's like my heart goes out to you
as a comic.
I know what it is to be a struggling
comic,
but there's nothing going on here.
But who does let guys to guest sets?
Who does what?
What does a lot of Comedians,
national headlines or just let the local
guys do guests sets.
I Dunno and don't you have to worry
about like putting on a good show?
Like if you put it on a guy who was
terrible and they would just ruin the
show.
These people paid a lot of money first.
So I will let someone have a guest spot
once.
And,
um,
this was,
uh,
on a,
a show with like in one of those ice
house type shows,
like 10 people on and he bombed so bad
that it tanked the rest of the night
because the people had to sit through 10
minutes of like really clumsy,
shitty jokes like from someone who like
barely does comedy,
you know,
I had find out later and then
afterwards,
like the audience had a lowered
expectation whereas before it'd be like
Ian Edwards,
Tony Hinchcliffe,
Tom Segura,
smash,
smash.
And everybody would be experiencing that
all night.
Well there's this 10 minute gap where it
was just sludge,
just like really shitty ideas and just
not done well and the audience went
whoa.
Like you could see them get super bummed
out.
Yeah.
Especially when you're on a good show
like that.
I've been lucky enough to go the past
few weeks to the store.
But Joey,
when it's really good shows it's fun.
But when there's like,
I went to a show once and there was a
magician on this on stage and it just,
I just,
I think of him because I know he hates
it,
but it's so weird how important it is to
build a good show and to build,
it shows the comics who global
altogether it's,
you can't just have,
you can't just throw a comedian's up
there and have a good show.
The problem is like people are friends
with people that you know,
and then you know,
they,
you know,
you know them and they know you and the,
hey man,
can I do one of those ice house shows?
Yeah,
sure.
Come on down.
Doucet I'll say,
and then you just go,
oh no,
what has happened here?
Jesus fucking Christ.
And if you do that like this,
this guy,
like it's written jokes that day and was
doing them that night.
He had never done them before.
Like,
can I try to do like a Ho?
So it's a long ass story.
But when that does happen,
the p the audience feels like you fucked
him.
You know,
like people always say like,
why would I take the bass comedians on
the road with me?
Like,
dude,
wouldn't you want to like stand out
front of the other comedians?
Oh,
the audience feels like you fucked him.
Then like you've made up for the fact
that you fucked him by being really
funny for the last hour and 10 minutes.
But you know you fucked them for the
first 20 minutes.
If you fill in the blank with the name
of the Comedians,
there's a bunch of crazy fucking
comedians that will open for other like
national acts and they don't work
anywhere else.
They just,
the work is like opening acts for big
time national acts who don't want to be
like showing up on stage.
They don't want someone going on before
I'm being really funny.
But isn't that the point of the opener
to warm them up?
Like that's why they have a studio warm
up people for TV shows because they want
them to have good energy and
I want you to warm him up to a degree
that you really have to hold back a
little bit because they're the star of
the show.
This whole stupid.
I rather we come from the school of
thought.
We want everybody to be fucking great
because of the guy in front of me is
fucking great while I'm back there
taking them,
watching this,
I'm going to come out throwing 92 miles
an hour if the guy's in front of me is
lack of days.
I,
it happened to me one time where you on
the road?
We left the gift set up.
The guy's energy was low.
I W he sucked me in when I went up there
and bomb because of him because I didn't
want to make him.
It was so bad.
I said,
I'm not going to do material now I just
go up to him and talk because it's a bad
thing that does happen when you watch
really bad comedy,
like someone who's like really amateur
level comedy.
It's something weird happens where you
get confused as to what's funny,
what's not funny.
It's like it's almost like a
smokescreen,
like one of the ink things at a squid
shoots and like,
yeah,
like you see someone on stage that's
really new and really bad and just you
got to get out of the room.
It's like why?
Like you can,
your mind can get locked into their way
of thinking because that's what I think
is happening anyway on stage.
I think the reason why comedy is so
funny,
it's because you're thinking like that
guy,
the guys
taking you for a ride and when you let a
bad comedian take you for a ride,
like you get stuck in like what they're
doing on stage.
Say if they're doing like real obvious
hack material,
cop donut jokes,
you know,
Tampon Chubb price check,
you know that kind of stuff and the
audience is really laughing.
You'll,
you'll get confused and your whole set
you like you have to shut him out and
like,
wow,
la La,
you've got to listen to some music.
You got to go onstage fresh.
Like they didn't exist.
You're better off not seeing them.
I don't want to see him no more.
I come out like gladiator.
Yeah,
you have to come out of that case like
Gladia.
I don't want to get caught up like
Friday or Saturday early show on what's
the other acts and I started getting
into it,
but until then I want to come out of the
box like a fucking savage.
Right.
But if you're working with people that
you love,
like if you were doing a show with
Dunkin and Ari,
you'd probably watch a lot of their set.
I would,
yeah.
That's the cool thing about when we do
the road together,
we watch each other.
Shit's fun.
It's like I get to see a show and do a
show,
you know?
It's fun.
I love going to the stores and the back
and laughing me to one of my all time.
Favorite things to get done a little
early,
like your spots at 10 45 you get none.
They were 10 and you watch a few guys
and it really gets you in the,
in the swing of things.
I was like,
yeah,
it really does get you going.
You know?
But I don't want to sit there all night
either.
Well that's a cool thing about the
store,
Zoe.
Some chose going on,
someone's three rooms can move around,
watch a bunch of different shit.
I think that's a not to be taken
lightly.
I think with anything.
I think if you were,
um,
you know,
if you are a knife maker,
if you are really into making custom
knives,
you'd want to be around other dudes and
make those things.
That's why they have those expos where
people get together and they,
it's what he'd been up to,
man.
What's going on here?
I mean,
there's no nine man.
It's doing a stainless steel.
Look at that.
There's a dude who,
Anthony Bordain did this thing when he's
done these videos about people making
shit.
This guy makes knives with metal from
meteors.
Where does he get the meteors?
Meteors like the fucking land on earth.
It can pick it up.
Yeah,
you can buy them.
And they're super expensive.
So He's,
he's getting his iron from space.
Look at this guy.
Whoa.
Look at that fucking knife.
Come on dude to Kramer knife.
This guy makes these things by hand who
can pull it's receiving and find the
video cause it's fucking crazy.
He's got like this herth I guess that's
what you call it,
right?
What do you call it when you some sort
of an oven where he's baking these
knives but with Bordain bordain is like
a,
he's a real lover of craftsmanship.
So this is making these things sort of
in a similar way to the way Samurais
made them.
Well you have big plates of metal and
um,
you,
you compress them and heat them up and
smash them and get all the layers into
one layer.
But it's all done with iron
that he's getting from fucking media
right now.
What's the difference between the IMF
and the media rights?
Just,
it's cool.
You could say it's from space.
It makes you,
so it's not a strong iron or nothing
like that.
It doesn't last.
I think I would,
as far as I know,
I mean there's ways to harden iron and
steel.
What survives coming.
He'll actually,
you,
we're talking about steel,
they're making steel,
but I'm using the iron from space.
Uh,
I don't think there's any benefit.
I think it's probably just really cool
looking and awesome to say.
It's just fucking steal.
I mean,
it is what it is,
you know?
Right.
Isn't that correct,
Jamie?
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Uh,
Captain America's shield that they got
from the right.
Exactly.
So this dude,
I think his name is Steve Kramer.
Bob Kramer,
excuse me,
Bob Kramer and Bob Kramer throws 'em
this giant chunk of metal and it's
unbelievably hot oven.
And then he pulls it out and then he
puts it in this machine and hammers it
and he's just talking about all the
different methods of hardening steel and
adding carbon and all the things that
they add during the process.
But it's crazy wild shit,
man.
Leave that.
So he pulls out this
orange and white glowing thing and they,
it pounds it down,
so he takes it and all those layers get
smashed down into a thinner and thinner
layer and it just keeps doing it over
and over again until it becomes like a
blade.
It's wild shit man.
So when it's down to being a blade,
that fucking thing is so compressed and
smashed down.
Just really interesting shit.
So what is the name of the video?
People want to watch it
raw craft with Anthony Bordain.
He's got a bunch of these.
He's done.
I don't know how the fuck that guy has
so much time.
Just so much shit.
There's like a few of those guys where I
feel lazy dude does personal speaking
gigs when eating out with their joint is
pray,
leaves,
pumpkin shoots a little bit of nature
bugs.
Joe Dan was nature bucks,
never killed nobody.
This guy's making fucking swords.
I mean that those guys want to be around
each other.
You know like if you're making knives
like that,
you're going to want to be around other
people to make knives as well.
It's like we're the,
one of the things about places like the
store is a,
we can all meet each other and hang out
like the other night in the bar,
like Stan Hope Ron White,
me bunch of us just hanging and I'm
like,
well where's their place like this?
Where we can meet like a s fucking
saloon where a fellow fellow travelers
can meet.
I got to tell you something.
Run.
Why this really taken to the store?
He has,
he's really taken to the store.
Like he's one of the guys and he gives
you a big hug.
He's got a drink in his hand.
He's happy as fuck up there.
He goes up there.
He the fucking room
in a slow,
methodical way.
But at first he would just stay back
there and go,
what the fuck is this shit?
This ain't right.
And yeah,
and I watched them.
I've been watching him just become a guy
at the store.
Yeah.
He's always in the back bar is always
hanging out with were bro.
He's always at a bar.
If there's a bar open,
he's close by the way.
Walking fucking with distance.
Okay.
That guy's the real fucking deal.
Yeah,
no,
he shows up with his own bottle and ice
cubes.
We has his own brand.
Right.
Tequila.
What is it called again?
Get Fuck Gut something.
That's what it's something won.
Something won.
Fuck's it called
number one.
Number one.
Yeah,
that's it.
Number one.
How racist number one.
Tequila Papa Ham.
It's good shit.
It is really good shit.
He had it at the meeting.
As far as that stuff goes,
it all tastes like shit really.
You know what I mean?
Let's be real.
Even the best tasting Tequila tastes
like shit.
The best tasting,
all that alcohol.
I never get the people.
I sit wine,
I started don't like wine.
I can drink a glass of wine.
You know it's,
it's still alcohol.
I still like Jack Daniels shot.
It tastes off as the shit out of me.
It tastes like shit and I love it.
You know what you're talking about that
that I still remember I was a little boy
in New York City with my mom and I let
leap for Joe Frazier.
Like I lived on 88th street.
Like I still remember how big that event
was.
Like if you asked me about events in New
York City,
one is Muhammad Ali,
Joe Frazier to and the early seventies
and Elton John came to New York City.
He fucked that city up.
The captain,
fantastic and goodbye yellow brick road.
When I was a kid,
he fucked up traffic.
Michael Jackson,
fuck up traffic of 84 you know,
he a couple of nights at the garden
then,
but Mohammed Ali,
Joe Frazier,
when I was a kid was fucking huge.
It was huge.
I remember crying.
I wanted to watch it.
I tried to get a blow job from my
babies,
so that was a kid.
She was a Puerto Rican chick named D.
Dot.
And I kept asking about blowjobs.
She goes,
I'll give you a blow job.
So I gave her a bag filled with quarters
that I had and she came into the room
and I took a shower.
I comb my hair,
I put Cologne on,
and she came into the room and blue on
my stomach and said,
that's a blow job.
And took my $20,
killed the dog.
I cried myself to sleep that morning.
My mom,
I woke her up like,
I got to talk with you.
My mom was like,
what is in broken English on my teeth
and stole my $20 and she said she was in
a suck my dick and she did.
And my mom's like,
what are you talking about?
What the fuck are you talking about?
You know,
like six or seven.
What are you talking about man?
I said I wanted a blow job.
I gave her $20 and then she took my 20
hours.
I'm gonna fucking kill him mom.
And my mom's like,
are you fucking crazy?
Why would she suck?
Get deck with $20 you can get other box.
Why would she suck you a little helmet
vic for $20 and shit you were,
how old is it?
Six seven.
How old was she dairy too?
When did Muhammad Ali fight Joe Frazier?
The first time?
71 maybe [inaudible] 71 I was probably
eight
I was a little kid,
man.
Your money.
Oh my mom had to give me back the 20 I
made my mom get back to me.
If mom gave it to you and my mom says,
what would it take to make this problem
disappear?
So she gave you 20 just to shut you up?
Yeah,
cause she knew I would help her teeth
and asleep.
I would kill it.
And the sleep,
she was sleeping on the couch,
the babysitter fell asleep on the couch.
This God,
you give me the $20 I'm going fucking
killer right there.
Asleep.
I was like are you fucking crazy?
I'll give you the 20 just leave Quito
alone.
I didn't talk to Peter for a year.
Doug,
she never talked to her again.
When was it?
Yeah,
one I was eight and she's ripping off
little kids.
She was great though.
Data that group.
Great.
Babysit this girl now.
I didn't like my mom going out at night.
My mom had the bar so I would spend the
whole day with my mom and then at night
you'd have to go to the fucking bar and
it would drive me crazy.
Joe,
I want to go to the bar.
Right.
You can't go to the bar.
You go to school.
I don't give a fuck.
Let me come protected size or weird.
I would fucking wait for it to get the
Jersey and I cause a war and the house
and she'd have to get back in the car
and come over the 88th street.
Fuck me up,
put me to sleep,
getting in bed with me and laid down.
And then she would go back to the bar
and fucking close it.
Hell man.
Hell.
And then when we moved in Jersey,
I would call her up.
I was scared at night cause I thought
the house was haunted.
So I would call her up and then you're
going to get down there.
I'd be crying and shit.
Violence.
You could just take a capital,
your friend's house asleep over there.
There was a year I didn't sleep at my
house.
You know,
really like a year when I was in the
seventh grade,
I didn't sleep in my house.
Never.
I would go there after school,
get clothes.
I didn't go to my friends house and
sleep there and lived there.
I was scared of fucking ghosts and shit.
My grandparents insisted their house was
haunted data guy.
Uh,
during the 50s,
who rented a room upstairs.
So local guy was a bachelor and he just
rented a room because um,
you know,
people did that back then they were poor
and uh,
that guy died.
I think he died while he's at the house.
I don't remember.
But they insisted that the fucking guy
was still like walking around.
They'd hear him walk around.
I lived there for months when I first
moved up to number and shit.
Then I realized,
you know what a lot of that is
people just get bored.
They want there to be a ghost.
They want something crazy to be going on
their board.
They don't have any excitement.
And so the only excitement is like being
in that room in the dark and having
feelings about something.
It's not even real.
Oh,
I feel something.
I feel presence.
I feel a presence.
Something that's wrong,
that's wrong.
We can get the fuck out of this room.
Oh,
well,
nothing happened.
It's just you're in the dark.
You're in the dark in an old house,
but your board is,
fuck.
That's what it is.
I don't know Joe.
I don't know dog.
I lived in,
I want the fucking house.
My mother bought this house in North
Bergen,
New Jersey.
I'm given that terrorists,
given that terrorist was originally to
give it to that
which one kids die.
Wouldn't parents die and kids go,
it was an orphanage to orphanage set
fire
in the forties so they took Charles
Court and given that terrorist and build
it over this orphanage.
There was an article about it on
facebook about six months ago,
but the whole given that terrorist
fucking spooky shit.
Yeah.
So in that house,
my mother bought him.
The reason why my mom,
my mom got in that with the alias was
because who came in with a heavy cash
and the guy killed himself in the
garage.
All right.
The,
I hung himself in the fucking 60 so
skids was selling the fucking house.
Well we didn't know about this.
I never knew about this til years later.
Once we moved in Lima.
In the beginning I was going to Catholic
school,
so I only slept her on the weekends.
Once I moved in full time.
Like in the sixth and seventh grade was
when I would hear that goes to at night
and went Jan,
I would hit them coming up the fucking
status and shit and I would cry and
yell.
Right.
So they sent me to the Santa Maria
Lady's House and she told me to put a
glass of water under my bed with a red
towel on the top and I would sleep
better,
but I would still do your fucking noises
at night.
I was fucking then,
that's all.
That's spooky shit.
Now do you remember when we did Tom
[inaudible] years ago and my friend
called girl with y'all.
We and I want to get coca.
Okay.
Her brother died on that block when he
was 1615 he died on that block.
This is silly ones.
And if you think Cuban people are creepy
with this Santa Rita and shit,
nobody's creepier than old school
Sicilians.
I mean she broke it down.
She kept telling me,
I told him,
my husband,
Sicilians don't live on dead end streets
because they're bad luck.
Like they broke.
Like when I see them now,
they still fly out here,
especially house and coming on.
The streets are bad luck.
Oh yeah.
The Sicilians,
I mean she's an old school Sicilian that
she took the fish,
the eyes from fishers to help people see
better help people.
You ever see the movie sleepers?
Which movies are sleepers heads explode?
No.
Let's scanners.
The fucking heads explode.
This is about 24 kids who rob up,
hot dog man.
And my mistake,
a guy dies and they send them to a jail
who was in,
uh,
look all star cast.
Brad Pitt was the priest.
I do go book is a lot better.
The movies suck because they put too
many stars in the movie.
Too many.
But that's about store fucking kids that
gets sent to an orphanage and they get
beat up or whatever the fuck it is.
But before that they go to work for my
boss.
If you've ever watched any of mafia
movie every month and blows the
characters.
The only mobster that was ever any good
in any Italian movie beside Marlon
Brando was the guy that played the
mobster and this movie put,
see if he could fly asleep as King Benny
King Manny was a bad motherfucker.
He wasn't Italian Act that they
recruited to come all week.
I didn't even speak that good English.
Wait till you see the king batty boy
king baddies explained to him that he
takes the eyeballs to this lady for
headaches.
When I was a kid looking at King Betty
King Benny is a bad mobile fuck.
Both
a King Benny has to go deal with fucking
brother's in Harlem and the guy says to
a man,
but you said this movie sucks dot movies
or five but him,
as you know,
it was in this movie.
You're Chubby Buddy,
the guy you did softball with that Mike
Star?
No,
the Spanish kid that you did that series
with,
he was a Spanish kid.
Lombardi Puerto Rico or Puerto Rican
get,
Oh,
I know who you're talking about.
He played that well,
he was last seen from that.
See if he was in last.
No,
no,
no.
The kid,
the Spanish gay plays fat.
Moncho.
Hmm.
So you have to have the scene from
sleep.
Is it the black guy when the black guy
says to him,
see if they have a scene from a movie
that sucks.
No,
no,
no.
He says to them,
God,
look at you.
You bring style to the game.
The Italian guy goes,
I can not help.
You.
Might Tailor is dead.
I mean,
this guy has got lines and this fucking
movie and they never talk.
He died years later,
like they were saying,
who the fuck is this guy?
The guy is just a monster.
Just my point is not about fucking
sleepers or the fucking guy.
What's the point?
I have no idea.
I'm seeing going.
I'm like,
I wonder how he's going to be talking
about what we're talking about.
We're talking about for kids and shit.
Like,
Whoa,
oh,
this is silly.
Are we talking about bad luck blogs?
They just have a spooky beliefs.
So they came to me years later and was
telling me all about this block.
How,
how many people had,
I had had bad luck on that block after
that.
Like the,
the maloneys died from cancer.
The both of them,
you know the parents,
the old rocks died from cancer.
The girl across the street died in a car
accident.
Raul,
I just robbed him.
Raul and his family.
I just took a stereo and they wouldn't
let him in my fucking bedroom for years.
How do you rob some of these houses?
And I hung out with the kid cause he is
later we became friends while they were
moving in.
I robbed Raul and his family and I took
the stereo.
Some kid took the fucking desk.
It was amazing.
And that would be talked to him anymore.
Rau,
old learner all ended up fucking moving
to the bronx in the eighth grade.
Over night they left.
They owed money on the rent.
So,
but he would come through my house and
go,
can't we go to your room and listened to
this time.
It a good idea.
Hilarious.
Yeah.
Terrible.
Do you ever look back on your past?
Go,
how the fuck did I become like an
upstanding citizen?
How did I become a regular person last
night I was telling him these stories,
so that was shaking.
Well,
I remember when I first met you,
you were always a great guy,
but you will,
you are way more dangerous like you
were.
You're a dangerous person.
You could do,
you could do some ridiculous shit.
You A,
you were very volatile.
There's a part of me that's a very,
very nice law abiding person that really
is as a part of me,
that's always one of the try to be a
nice person,
but there's a part of me that does not
comprehend a part of human behavior
because it would not be alive.
I was raised by no means at all.
What do you mean?
It's just stupid human behavior that I
see everyday now I wouldn't know.
I say acceptable and how I was raised or
how the people like rub her work.
So when I look at that on behavior,
my head explodes.
I really can't handle it and I didn't.
I got a beaten when I was 19.
That was such a great beaten.
It was worse than the one that been on
Hopkins put on Felix Tryna dread.
And that's the day I made my decision,
my hand to hand combat days room like,
God,
I don't need this shit in my world.
If you come into my world and get
disrespectful,
I'm going to hit you with a weapon.
I'm gonna hit you with a chair or a
bottle.
I threw a lot of bottles in the store,
a couple of glasses.
He definitely throw some shit at the
store.
I don't fuck around with people because
I don't like people fucking with me.
I'm really sensitive.
I don't know how to handle it.
But see,
I think it's,
it's one of the things we're talking
about when we were talking about um,
um,
p people who go to war and how they get
addicted to that feeling and then it's
almost like,
um,
like that becomes their world.
Right.
Well,
I almost feel like with,
with some people they become,
they become like real addicted to like
bad situations.
I was get addicted to drama is drama.
Like you don't know how to handle life
if there's no drama in your life.
There was times I would rob Joe Rogan
knowing that Joe Rogan knew I was on the
rob and my state of mind was not what,
not what not what
you'd cause and they just,
I didn't know how to live without the
swirl of danger,
you know,
and let's be honest,
the last 10 years I did blow and not
because of an addiction.
The last 10 years I did blow up because
I was addicted to that state of mind
were always,
you were always in need of something.
The thrill was going to get the coat and
driving them with the coke in the car.
Yeah.
That's something that you,
when you told me that it was the first
time anybody's ever articulated it that
way,
like what you are addicted to was not
even necessarily the drug.
It's the whole thing.
The driving and little danger of danger.
Police going to the guy's place to buy
it,
the cop,
everything.
I would look at myself after snoring at
two three in the morning and see this
person I didn't even recognize in the
mirror.
I wouldn't even want to look
at them cause I was so ashamed that I
let that position take over my mind.
It wasn't the fact of the call or the
whatever.
Are they getting my dick sucked or
they're doing dirty things.
It was the fact that drive and fronting
it and all the scamming that went what?
And somebody told me when I got locked
up,
they said,
you think of all the time you put into
scams thinking that you put that time
into doing something on a positive level
it,
there's no surprise that my life has
changed as much as I did without the
drugs because 60% of your mental state
was always in those drugs.
Don't matter.
For the other 40 was in comedy.
The other 37 wasn't comedy and the other
three was in God knows what the fuck it
was.
But 60% of your day is dominated by that
addiction or whatever drives you and was
some people,
they've described it as like the
addiction and having that addiction was
like almost like a built in excuse to
not live up to their full potential in
anything to try and do.
Absolutely.
You.
Oh well for starters it's not,
it's,
it's the personal blame.
You want that just in case if you fail,
you always have a fucking excuse.
Well,
what'd you expect?
I was having those problems those years.
You didn't have any problem having a
problem is when,
uh,
you know,
you get fucking shingled floor or your
family member has cancer.
That's a problem that happens in life.
The coke and all that shit is your own
men.
Men made dilemma.
Are you with me?
Like these are the things you create,
all these things you create.
You know,
I think about that last year I did blow,
I was ready to call 60 minutes.
Like I think of this state of mind right
now.
Like I had already a pitch for 60
minutes to explain to them that I had
found the cure for cocaine.
That if you do heroin on Mondays just a
little bit,
you will not snort the rest of the week.
Like I was really going to put 60
minutes.
I was going to get an agent and go to
CBS and go,
listen,
I got a groundbreaking idea.
There's no reason for rehabs.
We'll get that white powder.
You motherfuckers are going to war for
it
and we'll get that little white poppy
seed.
We'll make it into some pill and we'll
get people high on Monday cause the rest
of the week.
I didn't want to get high.
How crazy that I was doing heroin on a
Monday and it wouldn't let me do coke
the rest of the week.
I look forward to Mondays.
Fuck CSI Miami.
Why only Monday?
I Dunno.
I have no fucking idea.
That was just the guy that was just a
snorting it.
Yeah,
snoring at two little lines of heroin
just to get me out.
And what does it do?
Like what's the feeling?
Hit?
Tell me what it feels like when it hits
you.
Well,
it takes a couple of minutes to hit you
and you feel this weird thing and then
you feel like your blood pressure going
up and you feel like this euphoric
warmth.
You feel like this fucking warmth.
I felt like my body.
Do you ever take a wet shit?
It's warm and you could see if you shit
outside steams gonna come out of it.
That's what your body feels like that
warm.
And then I would get an urge to puke
for a couple of minutes.
I would gag and Puke a little bit would
come out of yellow and then after I
puked a little bit,
I would just go into this state of
fucking Mona's for four hours.
It was like smoking in because all day
and like just sitting there smoking
cigarettes,
looking at a window and I'd make believe
I was writing John Lennon type lyrics to
jokes until I looked at them the next
day.
This brilliance about a refrigerator.
Like I remember writing a bit about a
refrigerator once and looking at it the
next day and say thank God,
thank God I never tried it.
You know what I'm saying?
Like little things like just,
well that was hedbergs drug of choice
and his jokes,
man.
I mean
it's,
I think he's probably the best
nonsequitor joke I ever because all his
jokes are unrelated.
It's like,
here's a non sequitur.
Here's some other things I was thinking
about.
Here's something I thought,
here's how I saw.
And it was like I was listening to it
the other day.
He was like,
half of his jokes were only funny
because he was saying them,
you know?
But they were hilarious like he had,
he had a way of doing it that was kind
of like heroin comedy,
you know,
you be messed up during the week or no.
Ooh.
Ah.
It takes me a day to recover.
On Tuesdays I'd be out,
I didn't say nothing to nobody.
I was doing the heroin and I wasn't
doing coke.
It was really fun.
So you would be like sober Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday.
And then he'd look forward to the big
bump on Monday.
Yeah.
That kid,
he used to send it to me.
He used to send me $7 bags.
What kid?
His name was a bonehead.
He died from an old date.
How weird.
Yeah,
figure that was going to live forever.
I knew own head.
I knew bonehead from Ohio.
My rest and peace loss bone had broken
the taste.
Some of my bone had boneheaded was like
your boy.
He was.
I could go into a room with 90
motherfuckers and bone that little like
a date.
That bonus was a bad motherfucker dog.
I love bump bonding.
Her three brothers,
I love Dalton,
but bone.
That was two of the brothers were very
successful.
I believe in not bonehead was successful
as a plumber.
He has his own company.
He only went to crazy at night bone.
That bone it when I was 17 would take me
to mcsorley's hell house in New York
City.
Don't want Id.
He called the bartender.
I'm going to give them three mugs of
beer and give him three mugs or be and
give them a bowl of Chili mug.
Ed would take 10 bucks for the both of
us and he'd go to Washington Square Park
and he'd come back and he'd give me a
balance and by the meantime he would go
by his heroin and they buy these mixture
of pills and even melt them to the black
and whites.
They take us to a strip club in New
Jersey or something and they'd take us
home and the next day,
seven in the morning,
they'd strip this.
There's bone head in the fucking in the
fucking a plumbing van up.
And Dan that he was a functioning
addict.
He wasn't like your regular,
there's a lot of those guys out there.
And he had a chick
that was a 13 bailey,
she was half Asian,
half Irish.
Good.
They used to do heroin together and
they'd pass out in the living room.
Wait,
fuck.
And they both go to sleep and then I'd
be in the bedroom cause I just moved
that were bonus family.
Okay.
They were Italian Bro.
They were real fucking Italians and I,
the mother used to,
the mother was the first person who ever
made me an that grant.
She was a little Irish chicken.
She said that she used to say the word
Earl,
she couldn't say oil and she was the
bookkeeper for union 52 whatever the
teamsters,
the Labor is unit.
You know,
I was over there one day when I was 16
she goes,
you got a book,
not walk me to work tomorrow.
Get your book.
You could stop fucking being a hottie.
So I,
you know like a hod carrier,
like hod carrier for brick masons.
And she goes,
I can get you with the Italians over by
the brick mason cause she was from
hoboken.
So she got me a book.
I financed that.
She got a loan shark to finance it.
I loved these people.
This is,
if I'm thinking of Mike,
I don't like doing documentaries,
but I needed to do a documentary about
this family because it's the rise and
fall of it in American families.
I saw before my eyes as a child,
I went over there and ate with them.
You know,
I hung out with all three brothers by
the way.
Like I wasn't just friends or bone had I
not with Chrissy fish.
And I hung out with the little,
whatever his name was,
but bonehead was my nighttime guy.
Bonehead used to take me into the murky
waters of the underworld.
He could get me guns are shooting of the
medium.
Brother was a drug dealer in the 80s and
he drunk.
He sold big times coke and he used to
buy jewelry.
He used to put them in the tackle box.
So one night me and the younger brother
in the bed,
sleep and bone had comes in to borrow
money from us because he was going to
this.
They get heroin and he goes and I go
bone it.
I got to go to the back of the time,
the money on me.
He went into his brother's room and
instead of his brother was sleeping,
the drug dealer,
instead of just opening up the tackle
box and taking $40 down,
he took the whole tackle box and it has
40,000 in cash and the other 30 and
jewelry,
he went to the Bronx.
These are the best times of my life.
Once you go by comrade,
this is the best time,
like your war stories,
and he thought the house was haunted.
This was not a haunted house at all.
These people were decent Italian people.
Dad was a longshoreman and the mom was
in charge of the teamsters union and
they hung out with westies.
They hung out with the fucking,
the mother was friends with this dude
that was a a whatever for the West East
and he used to get me jobs.
He would get me jobs.
Casing joints.
You know when you have a summer job?
Nah.
He would tell me,
come in,
I want you to go in that warehouse.
I'm going to give you 200 and they're
going to give you one 80 I want you to
go in that warehouse and write down all
the alarms and Tommy where the safe is,
who walks around the safe and he would
pay me money.
This is a great house,
old school,
Italian house,
but back the bone,
that bone,
it has the fishing tackle box.
He's about to go upstairs to buy heroin
and shoot it.
He puts the tackle box and the garbage
can in front of the building and puts a
lid on it.
When he's upstairs shooting heroin,
the garbage bin come and they'd take the
40 large with the 30,000 and fucking
jewelry
to understand me.
I mean,
this was nonstop.
Another night,
boneheaded came home high on heroin.
He decided to make French fries.
So he put the pot out better than they
remember in the 80s they had those pots.
You could bring it home with the hot oil
and they would boil and you can throw
French fries.
America went crazy over him.
I forgot what they were.
Praised everybody,
French fry machines.
Everybody was making an onion rings and
shit.
Well,
he did the heroin and not up and it at
the thing went on fire.
We're of course,
we're all on the fucking house.
Oh,
Jesus.
All right.
I went to boil.
I wake up to buy boom and alarms and
awesome.
Kurt's waking me up and we'd go out of
the house and the father's outside and
the grandmother and the fire department
crawls on top of the roof.
Joe when they hit the fucking roof to
let the smoke out and fire trucks are
coming from the side lane ward and they
got the sirens in the middle of all
this,
the tate in the morning and we all look
around and go,
oh my God,
Emile still in the house.
Bonehead was still in the house on fire,
Bro.
They turn the fire off,
they go in and he's still with his feet
up.
When his hands draw just heroin.
Dad of his mind,
he slept through the fire.
Oh my God.
Everything.
When they woke up,
he goes on my fries.
This is how crazy this family was.
We have to fucking battalions out there.
We got half of nine 11 out.
You still fucking sleeping.
Oh my God.
It burned the house down.
Burn the fucking kitchen down and have
the bedroom.
They had to move to a hotel for six
months and they had [inaudible] the
grandmother
downstairs,
it was old school Italian,
but she couldn't smell.
So we Kinda,
we smoked pot.
We'd just go down there and blow smoke
in her face and grandma would pass out
in the wheelchair and that was the end
that,
I mean it didn't stop.
It didn't stop genes.
So this is why you get mad at people for
binge watching stuff on Netflix and this
is what you were talking about.
I get mad at everything.
What are you going to bother me for?
I get mad when people like he used to
hide the coke.
The medium brother used to hide the coke
under his car and I'd be walking down
the hill and I can see a little
container and that he didn't even have a
Maserati.
What's the other Italian call?
This is how much of a guineas these
motherfuckers were.
What's the other Italian car like you
said?
The avanti Avanti.
Oh,
okay.
I remember those.
Remember that piece of shit that was a
piece of shows up pieces of shit.
And you show me a piece of carbon trust
to anything Italian.
Oh my God.
That was the,
he tried to sell it to me once.
It like 20
I give it to you for two grants.
Yeah.
I drive it down.
The corner blows up.
Like I feel like if you buy a Ferrari,
I feel like if you drive that thing,
it's going to fall apart.
I'm black.
I like,
I trust German cars,
you know,
I don't trust people like me making
cars.
What's the other one?
The other one that Lamborghini is that
tally those things fall apart?
Do they really guarantee you just look
at them.
There's no way that starts the ugliest
fucking call.
And it was actually Lamborghini's don't
wound by Audi,
so who knows?
They might be like much better
engineered now I'm talking shit
obviously.
Okay.
I don't know that much about things
other than uh,
I know a lot about porsches,
but there's a lot of cars I don't
understand about,
but God,
those things are disgusting.
The avanti,
when a piece of shit disgusting sought
us out to me for two grand 30 look at
that thing.
It's crazy.
Lamborghinis or like the biggest like
here's my Dick Carr.
You can get right.
That's the closet.
I,
they had the doors open up sideways.
You walk out of that naked.
Like,
if I had that car,
just walk on with my dick out.
Like what bitches put up $20 bills as
you go.
I can get a mic jock strap.
Oh,
your boys sent this.to Syrah.
Sent this fanny packs.
Oh really?
I got my fanny pack to the Brim with
Reed.
He's got giant fanny pack.
Those are great for anybody and they fit
me the way really good for the travel on
the road.
You can get a lot of stuff and um,
yeah,
no,
that's true.
You glasses your license and your
passport.
Oh yeah.
Well you don't have my plane tickets.
Canadians.
They have to come down to America to see
you and they have a great time.
Don't get me wrong.
It's a road trip.
That's what I do in Buffalo.
Buffalo,
Toledo.
I tried to really give me money for
Seattle,
Detroit,
Detroit.
I do grand harbor,
grand rapids,
grand rapids.
I'm trying to get the handle on it,
but next year.
And I remember we did that once.
Did I do that?
I did that once with,
uh,
I think Ari,
I ain't no harbor back in the day.
That's a college town,
right?
The comedy club down there yet.
You did it with something.
Yeah.
Oh,
I did it with the girl.
You came back and told me to call you
like gold called them.
Yeah.
Fun People.
Fun.
Fucking club fun.
Yeah.
There's some good spots where people can
come down.
The Canadians can come down like,
well,
he can't do Seattle either.
Ugh.
I can't do,
I know who he is.
The word fucking tear Seattle apart.
So sad he can't get into Washington
state.
There's still breaking my balls too.
Can you work that out?
I thought you already had that almost
two years ago.
You don't want men,
they want a bunch of cash and they still
want me to go up there and surrender
myself,
so fuck all that.
I'm not surrendering myself.
I ain't fucking surrendering yourself.
What does that even mean?
Come on in and turn yourself in and
we'll put you through the process.
12 hours in the holding thing and I
shit,
that ain't going
to King County fucking jail for that
shit.
12 hours in a holding tank.
It's not like you're some threat to
society.
Why do they have to put you in a holding
tank?
What kind of weird formality is that?
Like sorry,
we have to cuff you.
Well wait a minute.
You know I'm not and I have no failure
to appears like I've,
I've always gone to court.
I never,
I don't have a failure.
I even went to court with an alias.
Like I used an alias one time when I got
arrested,
that's the class I got.
I covered the spread.
When they arrested me,
I gave him like Joe Rogan's name and not
so you wouldn't get a warrant.
I went down and did the 16 hours
community service in the age of unit
painting for the age people.
So next time you look at me and tell him
he ain't got no fucking character,
think of that.
And 10 years later I go to eat dinner
with that guy and he's like,
can I have a Tan?
I got pulled over and I had a warrant in
Colorado.
I got,
we got the rest of them Colorado for
shoplifting.
No Way.
I just kept eating my fucking meal
but at least he didn't get arrested
cause it's fucking time proof.
I did my fucking thing.
That is so ridiculous.
You imagine getting arrested in boulder.
I think about the words you told me
about boulder once you go.
I was driving into boulder and my wife
and I kept thinking this must've been a
candy store for Joey did.
Yeah.
How do you get arrested?
They let you out without a life.
They're all like barefoot.
Yoga people listened to me.
I was in jail for three weeks as Jose
Diaz waiting bail for kidnap me.
I sat in there from December,
from November 18th to December like
ninth to 10th I had the jail.
Why'd you do know that?
You do know that I could just go up to
the gardens I need to make along with
business call and he let me out.
Everybody else had a sign the list.
You do know that when I was smoking weed
and then I had all access to cool lake,
cause I don't like,
I hate fucking milk.
I like Mo shakes.
Not Know I had all access.
Do you know I got arrested three months?
Not even Joe Rogan.
I got the rest of the month after I made
bail and they put me back in that jail
and I went back as Jimmy
and everybody was calling me Jimmy.
No,
no,
no.
My name,
I'm the fingerprint was the alias and
their fingerprint and me calling me Joey
doing joey.
How's it been lately?
I see you're back in here.
Meanwhile,
on that card it blatantly says Jimmy.
So they didn't read the card?
No,
they just assumed it was you.
But you went in with someone else's.
Yeah.
And then what happened?
And then I called the girl,
they said,
we can't let you out without a license.
So your driver's license,
yet I didn't even have the license for
that name.
In those days,
there was no paperwork on me at all.
If you,
if you arrested me,
guess
always like jeopardy.
Right.
And here's your chance to beat jeopardy.
You get no prices.
I never carry the license on me in those
days till till this day.
I hate that bulge in my pocket.
I fucking hate it.
So what you do?
So I wouldn't bring an idea with me so I
can be anybody.
When you were arrested,
how could it be a fucking penguins?
Well you fucking
so you just had nothing on nothing.
So they made me call.
So I called my girlfriend at the time
and I go,
hey,
how you doing?
This is James.
She was like,
Ooh,
I go,
this is James.
I took you out to dinner a couple of
weeks ago.
I lost my license.
She's like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
I'm just a cops right there.
I'm like,
I lost my fucking license and these cops
won't let me out one unless somebody
comes down here and lets me,
I'm not,
she knew the kid,
I was talking about
you following me.
She always heard me talking about him.
I said,
James,
James.
And she goes,
Okay James,
this last name.
And I go,
yeah.
And she went down there and they brought
her in.
They said,
what's his name,
James,
where does he live?
She told them and they go,
okay,
we'll let you out.
That was it.
They gave me paperwork and four days
later I turned myself in.
I went,
I stood in court,
I got charged.
I pled guilty because I didn't want to
fuck with it.
I didn't want to take a chop with
things.
Think the trial they had me and I
fucking did the uh,
community service at the age unit under
this guy's name,
under this guy's name,
that 16 hours of the fucking,
the community corrections.
But I met a cop that was there.
So see everything works itself out and
throw the other,
because when I was there,
there was a cop that would do a detail
that in those days,
the police age,
that AIDS unit was getting death threats
from like militant people in Boulder.
The people up in the hill and they had a
cop there and I would talk to the cop
every day,
talk to the cop a little bit,
hey,
how you doing officer?
And we'd talk about this or that,
and one day I got into a beef,
I had two felonies and my ex fucking
boyfriend thought he was tough for me
and I said,
you know what?
I got to smack this guy,
but if I could get them,
I got to get them good.
And I went to meet him and I fucking
smack them.
I guess it was the first cop on the job,
the dude from the AIDS unit.
This guy's holding onto his face.
He came,
he asked me,
Charlie,
what happened?
I told him the truth.
They gave me a ticket.
So life is his circle of my foot kind of
ticket.
They get for slapping someone.
He got a ticket to,
he got a ticket,
I got a misdemeanor assault and he got
using a racial slur outside the city
limits of boulder.
Oh,
is that really the case?
That's a really cool is always been like
that.
Yeah,
because the football players and 85
those football players that were really
powerful that that those teams that won
the national championship,
there was always beef with them in
boulder.
The cops always had beef with them.
So there was one,
there was a couple of incidents.
It was Kuneva Magee.
He just smacked them motherfuckers.
I ball out of his head.
I told those,
you think I'm kidding,
I'm not cracking jokes.
He broke his eye socket six foot five to
45 well that smack with a smack Jesus.
Oh Stockton slap I ball went out of his
fucking head weight made money,
had a ring on.
And then another lady called Jj Flanigan
a nigger and he punched her in the face.
So they dropped the,
because she
said a racial slur.
That's hilarious.
So when a woman can call a guy in and
just get punched in the face,
oh he slapped the,
so they call it the Jj Flannigan rule.
So like God is so crazy.
When I got arrested for that racial
thing,
I told him,
he called me a Spec what she did in
front of my daughter.
So I smacked him.
So wait a minute.
Did the football player smacker or
puncher thank you smack that Jj
Flanagan.
That's a street corner in the bolt and
Pearl Street mall is something that's
how strong that word is just smack.
And Zoe is the only word that it has a
letter.
Like you could kind of say the f word,
but most people say fuck.
But he was still,
this is still 88 this is 88 this is
named d.
These are the times when they would come
down and see you football,
you know?
But they had a lot of shit going on.
Like there's a document,
there's a 30 for 30 Oh really?
Okay,
great.
Let me ask you this,
why do you think boulder has always been
so liberal?
Because they want to be,
they had that right to be,
these are people that want to live,
you know the boulder now I'm others will
go set him.
So Santa Monica,
it's the same fucking people.
What do you mean it's the same people?
That was not the bold and when I got
there in 1980 not even close.
What's the difference?
I don't know.
What the gentiles,
you know,
starbucks,
that's not what blogging was.
Stalls to be.
Boulder was totally brought up to be
anti very much establishment.
Very uh,
you know,
people who have soap companies,
right?
People who have shirts with designs of
the grateful dead.
But that's what it is.
Right?
If that's what it is,
let that be that.
Well there's a bunch of people in
Boulder,
it'll just go democrat no matter what,
which means they just vote Democrat.
Oh No,
they don't vote Republican ever.
So like when I was there,
it was,
it was during the Obama election after
he got elected for the first term is
when I was there.
And uh,
I was like this,
it's so weird that there's so many
different people that have the same
thing on their front lawn.
It's Obama,
Obama,
Obama like everywhere you look,
he didn't see any Republican candidates
on anybody's launch.
So you just didn't see that.
What is the rest of Colorado like?
Way Republican,
way more republican rest of Colorado is
like cowboys and shit.
Denver's kind of a mixture.
DENVER,
you get a little bit of everything cause
it's sort of like Austin,
Texas,
like that sort of like no,
no,
no because Austin is more like cowboy
funky.
Austin's different.
Austin is like a lot of bad ass music
comes from Austin fucking Gary Clark Jr
comes from Austin.
But the state of mine of Wash of Boulder
and Austin were pretty much similar
representing that the states.
But you can't compare them because most
there's only a hundred thousand people.
It's tiny ass place.
Austin's a million.
What's the population of of bold?
100,000 still.
It's tiny bates camp build.
They don't let you build.
They got that place locked down.
Well that's what I'm saying.
They always buy up open space.
Boulder always
wanted to be different than everybody
else.
Yeah.
When I first went to boulder,
I first peaked at Boulder July of 83 and
I was like,
I'll never come to this fucking place
too boring.
But I was from New York City Guy Get us
the population Jagan find it was an all
of a sudden I'm dealing with pizzas and
slept on a mattress about 300,000 but
it's 100,000 the Metros 300,000 Oh,
okay.
So it's about you hundred thousand
weight [inaudible] we doing stepping
back to chew.
You were in the middle of the store.
Yeah.
Boston's a totally different animal.
Austin as much more like a,
I just meant in the way like Texas is
right repo.
Yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
But there's a lot of Republicans in
Austin.
Austin's not entirely liberal.
Austin's a mixture.
It's a weird mixture.
Boulder's not much of a mixture.
Bolger like Greg for Tim and said it
best.
He's like,
it's just too one note.
He liked a denver because uh,
we were talking about like how amazing
Colorado is and he did a weekend at the
comedy works.
He's like,
you know what,
I could fucking live here.
He goes,
I don't really say that about many
places,
but I could live there.
And we were talking about bolder and
he's like,
I think bold is just a little too one
note.
They're a little too college influenced,
Super Liberal,
social justice,
Warrior type,
Vegan,
barefoot,
handcrafted,
all that nonsense.
You know,
there's like a lot on the People's
Republic of Boulder.
That's what they call it.
Leap is Republic of Boulder Place.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's listening to me.
He's folding the traction.
They're very nice people at that time in
my life.
Bold or just meant something to me.
It meant peace of mind.
I Dunno.
I don't know what the place itself is so
fucking beautiful.
I mean,
you're there in the foothills of the
rocky mountains and you just sit
sometimes he just like,
you'd go to boulder,
he just,
what's that street?
That Mall Street Pearl.
Pearl Street.
Pearl Street Mall.
And when you just look up and you see
and you're looking at fucking,
he leave the street and you look up,
you're looking at like mountains.
So rocky mountains right there.
Like you're in this beautiful,
amazing spot and the people,
it's not that many people.
I think that's a big thing.
I think when you get too many people in
a,
in a place that gets annoying that you
fucking don't appreciate each other as
much.
Just too many fucking people.
There's 3 million people has grown a lot
since I left Hawaii,
Florida.
It has butters,
can't grow much more than it's already
grown.
What they've done is amazing.
His bio up so much open space and make
it super difficult to put up apartment
buildings and people like that's
bullshit.
We need affordable housing.
Drive to boulder,
stupid fuck drive there just fucking be
part of the Denver Metro areas included
in that 300,000 that's okay.
Arvada and places like that.
Well it's like,
uh,
it's awesome.
Longmont,
Lafayette,
you know what's the hidden gem?
Evergreen Evergreen's this is the shit.
God Damn,
they have some views.
Evergreen has some ridiculous views or
you just tucked in with like this giant
elk herd that walks down through the
middle of town,
got a giant elk herd walking through the
middle of the street and a buddy of mine
moved there and he was living in Vegas
before and he,
and you know,
he was asking him about Colorado.
I said,
you've got to check out evergreen.
And he,
he went there once,
bought a house,
immediately moved.
And uh,
he texted me that these elk,
they get in the middle of the street and
someone who was from out of town
apparently was like beep in and trying
to get the elk out of the road and like
revving his engine and cause he was in a
rush and some old cowboy got out of his
truck,
walked up to dude's car window,
punched him through the car window and
then got back in his truck,
get sick because the guy was harassing
the helicopter.
Yeah,
that's no joke,
dude.
That's really what happens in evergreen.
This is a herd of elk walking down the
middle of the street and you can't do a
God damn thing about it.
And because the people in the town
itself,
I mean they don't really hunt them when
they do that.
So the,
the,
the elk feel super calm about walking on
the highway in front of everybody
because if they were in the woods with
you like that,
they would fucking bolt of,
they saw a person,
they smelled you,
they would bolt.
But meanwhile these things have chosen
to go like by the road.
It's interesting too because they,
they don't recognize people as predators
in those situations.
It's like people around urban areas
aren't predators,
but people in the mountains are
predators.
It's real weird.
So for generations that like [inaudible]
group of Alex has just been walking down
the street.
Yeah.
Unbelievable.
It's crazy.
Not only that,
um,
I mean that's the case everywhere.
Like in yellowstone,
there was a,
a video that someone sent me today.
I didn't,
I don't think I retweeted it.
Um,
someone send me,
I didn't watch him,
I wasn't getting self service,
but there's a video that someone sent me
today about some woman and got too close
to an elk in yellowstone.
I guess it was real recently,
but mo for the most part,
they don't worry about people they're
wearing about wolves and grizzly bears
and shit.
So they see a person they go,
cause no one's hunted in yellowstone for
over a hundred years.
So elk see people there and they were
like,
what's up dude?
How you doing?
Man?
Got some carrots for me.
Is this it?
Yeah.
Yellowstone elk decides a woman's too
close for comfort.
Yeah,
go,
go.
Oh,
oh,
oh no.
Oh No.
Oh yes.
Did you get that on video?
Oh.
Oh,
she just got launched
ma'am.
Could you please?
Oh yeah.
Oh yes.
Video.
I didn't get it.
Look,
she,
she went salen
the video.
Whoa,
you're too close to got out.
And that's why
25 yards,
ma'am.
Thank you sir.
That's the,
I just got humbled,
sir.
That's a certain kind of,
Have you seen the video of the hunter
getting beaten by a whore?
A deer?
Yeah.
Saying this,
there's a bunch of hits in the face.
A Dell,
they'll fuck you up.
Especially in the Rut.
They're horny and they think you cock
blocking them.
They get mad.
Jack,
you are you sure?
Oh yeah.
Did people died from deer?
A lot of people had died because they
get gored like the,
you know,
they're hot.
They're either hunting homer there,
hiking him or what for whatever reason
they may be like that lady,
they get stupid.
Like she was lucky that that was either
a cow elk or that was an elk that didn't
have antlers yet cause they shed their
antlers and then the grown back.
Um,
so she got lucky cause if that was a big
bull elk,
there's one,
this one,
this is the one I saw.
He just kicked him.
That guy has dog shit Jujitsu.
First of all should be spinning for one
of those rear legs.
You try to get them in a heel hook on
that real.
I,
uh,
comorbid a deer's lag and snapped it in
half after it was already dead.
I was trying to,
I was like,
I wonder if this would work.
A deer snapped its leg when Callan and I
and went hunting in Montana.
So I feel real confident that I could
heal.
Hook a deer.
Fuck it up.
Have you lost your fucking
deal?
I take us back.
Take us back.
Take that fucking,
then you're in the hospital with a ball.
By the way.
My fault.
Probably just recovering right now.
Yeah.
He's in the hall in the hospital today
and he got his,
his discs replaced.
How long does that take now?
Um,
I don't think the operation is,
uh,
just a few hours and I'm,
the recovery time is a ridiculously low.
I think a,
in six weeks he's allowed to start
lifting weights.
So six weeks,
his body has to heal up.
So I'm talking out of school cause I
don't know the exact procedure,
but I know this is what he told me is
that they're replacing a disk with a
titanium disk.
They have some sort of a new technology
in disc replacement where they used to
take the disc out and then they would
fuse it together.
Right now instead they'll put an
artificial disc and it's supposed to be
just as good as um,
uh,
a real desk.
And the difference being that like when
they would fuse those discs,
it would limit your mobility pretty
drastically because you don't have any
articulation in between the two joints a
now that they have this artificial disk
that aren't dead,
artificial disc actually moves around
and it allows your spine to be flexible.
So I'm one of the guys from school,
Victor got it done and apparently he's
never been better and it feels great.
No pain at all.
And it was bothering him for a long time
and Eddie's been bothering his for
almost as long as I've known him cause
he does so much stuff from his back.
You know,
it's all guard work and it's getting
stacked all the time and compressed all
the time and not,
you know,
not the most diligent about stretching
the back out early in his career.
You know,
just he take your stretching before and
after you who you definitely should warm
up before.
Um,
but the big thing is mobility,
mobility,
training meaning,
um,
doing things like bending down,
grabbing the back of your heel with your
four fingers on both sides and trying to
put your pinkies together and then
extending your legs and you're popping
your back and stretching your back.
For me,
that's big.
Hanging by your ankles as big and he
sort of decompression anything that
alleviates pressure.
I have one that I put on my neck and
it's like I'm hanging myself and go
click,
click.
And I'm like literally hanging a good,
good percentage of my weight from my
neck.
Then I have a bunch of them in the back.
I have different,
uh,
decompression devices in the back.
I've got the reverse hyper,
which strengthens your back.
And also it's like an active,
moot moving decompression of the bag
that's created by that.
Uh,
Louie Simmons guy that from a west side,
barbell,
just genius guy.
He had a back injury too and you needed
to get it fixed and they were going to,
they wanted to cut him and he was like,
ah,
I think I can figure this out.
I think there's gotta be an exercise.
It strengthens this instead of surgery.
And so that's what he came up with.
But see in Eddie's position,
don't even know if that would have
helped because Eddie's was so far gone.
He didn't have any disc left.
There was like,
there's nothing there.
You know what?
I'll burrow those.
They do look 12 o'clock class then at
one 15 it's a mobility class for half
hour.
And I said that Kettle Jitsu guy.
No,
but isn't there a guide?
Yes.
Now,
but he's got tip,
tick,
fit,
fit.
He's got tick fit.
What does that mean?
Tick fit?
Is that new training with the bats?
How'd he say tick?
How do you spell it?
T I see fit I think.
Huh?
Take fit.
And it's the stuff with the bat.
Okay.
Like Eskrima like that kind of stuff.
No one is police baton.
What do they have happen on it now?
What do they do for,
oh,
you mean macy's?
Like Steel Mace or on a club?
They have the club.
Phillip were playing charades.
The club.
The club on the metal club.
Yeah,
it was great.
It was something with a club and they
have a class at nine.
Oh,
okay.
And then they have a class at one and
they have a class at six 30 what he's
been doing lately,
he's like,
you know what man?
My one's been like,
why did I come out here and do mobility
with you guys from one 15 to one 45 I
feel like class warmed up and ready
after Jujitsu and he just does,
you know,
a squat.
Touch the ground,
lift your foot down and go up and switch
legs.
You know,
just stuff like that.
Six exercises,
three minutes with a,
with a thing and you're out of that.
You're stretching your rob,
then it's no,
no big deal.
I mean,
you break a sweat on some of them,
you know,
downward dog to something else into it
and do push up.
We know it's problem with Jujitsu is
that it's fun.
And when it's fun,
you're going in there and getting
smashed all the time and the overall
look,
you don't give yourself a lot of time to
recover from those rolling sessions and
there's a lot of little micro injuries
and those rolling sessions and some of
those micro injuries become chronic.
After awhile.
Like Eddie's back or like for me it was
my neck just like over and over again.
You're doing the same thing over and
over again.
You're out sore the next day.
Just keep training,
you keep crying.
He'd developed scar tissue.
Your disks get compressed and then you
start weird shit like
numbness like some guys get like numb
feet like a cade.
My friend.
Kay.
Does lower leg is still numb.
Still Numb.
Yeah.
My hands,
I was getting numb hands,
bas rutten's got it.
Like a whole,
his whole like neck area is fucked.
He's had several surgeries in his neck
and his,
he's get at least two disks,
maybe three discs frozen and,
and,
and fucking like the,
the disks are removed and the,
the bones are fused in his neck.
I tried to take a day in between except
with days that I have to go on the road.
The weeks I'd have to go on the road,
I want to get three.
And so I just do it Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday and got on a plane Thursday.
But the weeks I'm in town all week I'll
do Monday,
Wednesday and Friday.
And then sometimes like this week I did
Sunday and I went Monday.
But Sunday is very light.
It's just a three minute roles and guard
pass past stuff.
He's a great guy.
He doesn't really hate Mondays.
Wednesdays and Fridays are hard.
Wednesdays,
Sundays I go cause the guy is just so
great.
Technically I always learn one little
stupid thing,
you know,
just one little stupid thing.
Your role like two or three times in
your out of that.
Right.
So I always tried to take,
he was,
if I want to go that day,
even if I feel okay and I'm not sore,
I'll take the day off because I don't
want to go every day.
I don't want to do that.
You know,
I'll do a light kettlebell workout or
something.
But then there's other people that think
you just keep doing it and eventually
body hardens up.
Yeah.
I don't know.
It's uh,
it's,
it depends.
I guess it depends on how you approach
it.
I know bordain does it every day.
The trains every day sometimes does
twice a day until it,
he'll take a private and then I'll take
a group class.
Well,
it's an,
it's an age thing.
It's to time barrier and it's also,
um,
like for me,
it's the weight.
You know,
when you judo throw me,
it's 300 pounds.
It's driving the five.
You do that 10 times.
The next day something's going to be
rattled in my fucking head.
Right.
Okay.
Last week we had a guy,
Rick Gay Machado.
He's Jack or race coach and the Amazon.
You got to take Wayne,
uh,
boke and a fucking bicycle.
You know what I'm like,
I'm not,
I'm not trying to be cute.
It's true.
We had our burden on him.
I'm about,
Britta was saying that the one place in
Brazil that you got to train 10 hours,
then you've got to walk a mile.
Then you've got to go across and one of
these things,
there's some days somebody would steal
the paddle.
Can you imagine Jesus?
10 hours a fucking fucking around our
mile walk and now some of these steals
the fucking battle.
I can't even battled through my fucking
house and there was shit in the water
and there was shit.
No water cause that the house,
the sewage would go into the water.
Oh Jesus.
No,
no,
no.
And then you wonder why they got Zika
and everybody's head's getting big in
Brazil and shit.
It was small.
That's what I'm now how's,
uh,
I think that's what they gave Jose Aldo
is to fight against mcgregor,
the Zika virus.
They're all fucked up.
They had them crying after the show that
had a camera in the room.
I'm telling you,
Dana,
find a way to give them the Zika virus
is shit.
Imagine how bad the population would be
if there was no viruses.
If there was no diseases,
diseases didn't kill anybody.
I mean,
how many people are killed?
Let's just take a guess.
How many people are killed every year by
disease?
Let's guess 2 million,
3 million.
How many people you think probably
around there,
but it's not in America.
I think it's in like,
right.
Did she get that picture?
By the way of that,
that a ladder and China,
China kids were climbing at places like
that.
Like it's like a 2000 foot bamboo ladder
that like six year olds are climbing up.
Why are they doing that?
It's the only way to get to their town.
So I think that,
yeah.
Have you seen that Jamie?
Jesus Christ.
A 2000 foot ladders.
It might not be feed.
It might be.
Look at this.
Oh my God.
Children in China would climb 2,500 foot
cliff to get to school,
maybe given stairs.
Oh,
pussies.
They're six years old.
So it's pulling like this.
Look at this dude.
They're climbing with their backpacks on
you.
Imagine sending your little baby and
your baby has to climb 2,500 feet on
this Janky ass wooden ladder that looks
like it was made when Columbus was
sailing.
Cut.
Fucking wanky.
That ladder looks,
that's insane.
See if there's any other pictures
that is fucking bananas.
Oh
well was poor kids.
They got a hard look in their face,
man.
Jesus,
that's so crazy.
I wonder,
do you know there's one fucking weak ass
bitch kid that starts crying.
They meg and then he falls.
I was everyone down.
Not In China,
not in China.
They don't make it.
Those kids don't make it.
That has been Nana's.
So yeah,
I think it's places like this where
people are dying of viruses cause you
don't,
you never really hear about it in
America that often.
Well people definitely die of the flu
here in America.
That's still happening.
I bet thousands of people die every year
from the flu.
But as far as how many people die from
diseases worldwide?
I'm going to say every year.
I want to say 20 million.
How many?
How many people?
It depends on like what kind of disease
cause there's lots of disease.
Cardiovascular disease.
Oh yeah.
It was different.
But that's like,
that's just like poor health.
It says 2012 an estimated 56 million
people died.
Just died in America.
The whole world?
No,
no.
56 million.
1 million in the hole.
It was America.
That'd be like in one year.
That'd be a sixth of the country.
That wouldn't happen just America but in
the whole world only 56 million people
at a 7 billion.
And the either estimation I didn't,
they can't count on it.
Would you have guessed that that would
be what it was?
Uh,
I don't know.
I would have thought I'd been way
higher.
What would you think?
Like pre or like how many people die in
the year?
Actually I think 56 million is a pretty
big number.
If you really stop,
think about it.
And they're not counting anybody in
Africa.
No good luck.
Certainly people in Canada that's twice
that at least twice I guess.
That makes sense.
When you say disease,
this is HIV,
syphilis and Medina crabs,
flu,
Zika,
Zika.
I don't think Zeke is really killing
many people just fucks up.
Kids just really fucks women up when
they,
when they get apparently you can get and
not even know you have it.
Get pregnant at fucks your kid up.
Non Communicable disease is responsible
for 38 million of those.
Okay,
so that's like heart disease and
cardiovascular.
11.6 million.
But I want,
I want,
what I'm interested in is like malaria
and shit like that.
HIV,
uh,
decreased slightly from 1.7 deaths and 2
million to 1.5 million sold in 2000 or
200,000 less.
1.5 million people die every year from
HIV.
Diarrhea is no longer among the top five
leading causes of death.
Diarrhea and aid.
Neck and neck
people die from diarrhea.
Chorus.
Yeah,
they get dehydrated.
But how bizarre is it that that aids
kills that many people?
HIV deaths decreased 1.7 million to 1.5
million in 2012.
That's still crazy.
Like when was the last time you heard
about someone in America dying from HIV?
You don't hear about it very often.
They say complications and they usually
just something later.
It gets a deficiency is something that,
yeah,
that definitely can be it.
You don't,
my uncle got whatever we cancer four
years ago.
Dot.
Whatever with cancer.
He got diagnosed with cancer.
Okay.
Crazy one on west.
Really?
When I pulled the gun on,
you know he's still alive.
That happens.
No Chemo.
What does he do?
Change his whole diet.
No sugar.
Everything is organic.
Really.
Everything was Vegan and what happened?
He's still alive.
He still works the door on his bar.
He just bitch slap somebody.
About three months ago,
he still walks five miles a day.
Griffith Park and he still gets the bag
for now.
What's his cancer like to get it checked
out or it's just this fuck.
This is from testosterone.
Cancers from testosterone with
testosterone.
Since he was 35 he had three households
going.
It's got three households going.
What do you mean?
He had the wife and the kid,
oh this year told me that he cheated on
her.
He had the hook her for 30 years who we
still has a relationship with and then
he fucked her cousin.
She had a kid that lives in the
backyard.
Boris.
I got him in the back.
Oh my God.
We household through not just what they
all know about each other.
At least everybody,
buddy.
No,
that's good.
Everybody is,
otherwise it'd be too much pressure.
The fucking,
the wife just brought
the kid home after he fucked the cousin
because it's like,
all right.
He was fucking the straight when they
fucked her cousin once she had the kid
and she goes,
you went back with my cousin.
She just walked the kid to his house one
day.
She goes,
I don't want this fucking kid.
This is your problem.
And she's never seen the kid say,
oh my God,
my uncle's got them in the back like
Boris.
Oh my God,
I'm whipping him.
His shit he's got cover was that,
it's so crazy.
It's fucking career.
Three households.
I have a hard time with my daughter and
my wife.
Never mind three fucking households.
Do you see a guy like that?
Does that just cause to for a
distraction or is he just retarded?
He's retarded.
He's retired now.
He's banging a new one that's like
funny.
And how old is he?
78 he's got a 40 year old,
a 40 year old man.
He hooks up,
went on Thursdays,
and it takes it to the fish market.
You go to Orlando,
real weird place.
Tell your girl,
well,
he takes it down.
There's a fish market.
So you saw the natural fish and shit.
Right?
And he fucks the shit out of and he
brings home,
it gives us some lung cancer.
It gets a little heavy duty,
cancer day.
Any rocks her world would.
So the whole family's concerned because
they know and he punches the ticket.
He's going to leave all his money to
her.
Ah.
So everybody's pissed.
Don't make with like,
we don't know what goes on Thursdays.
I do,
but get your clock swigs isn't that
funny that people worry about that?
They're worried he'd like something more
than them when it comes to the money.
Where's the money coming?
You know,
man,
it's one of the ugliest,
I just got a call from a school teacher
and he goes,
I'm sorry I haven't gotten back to you.
He goes,
I've just had the hardest to once in my
fucking life.
My mom died.
What a fucking nightmare.
What a fucking nightmare death is.
And then there were big because nobody
gives a fuck.
And also it's like prince.
Prince dies.
No will.
$2 billion.
Six motherfucking savages.
He had $2 billion.
What?
He had 250 million.
Fuck.
He really had no,
well I've heard that a lot of things.
Talking about how,
how an investor involved in copyright.
He was with his own music,
which is especially why I changed his
name and to think he would not think to
have a will.
It seems really strange.
Some people who think it's bad luck.
Yeah.
Prince was crazy.
Just crazy.
Like you think that that would be odd
for him to not have a will?
I don't know.
I don't,
I don't think it would be that odd.
He was so odd anyway,
being that invested in your money cause
that's what he was worried about with
knowing all this thing.
That's the last,
I don't know.
Maybe it doesn't care valuable.
Maybe didn't want to be valuable when he
was dead to family members and shit.
Maybe he did want to like have that.
He's like,
who cares what happens to my money when
I'm dead?
The problem is the government gets a big
chunk of it.
If you don't have it written off,
if you don't have a given off to,
uh,
various family members,
I,
the government gets up fat piece,
but don't they still get a piece?
They definitely get a piece.
They get a piece.
Not only do they get a piece,
they get a piece from money that you've
already been taxed on.
Like say
of Joe,
he makes $1 million,
right?
And Joey is $1 million in the bank and
he leaves it all to you.
Joey didn't make $1 million to get $1
million.
He had to make way more than a million
dollars.
So he probably had to make closer to two
because when you get over $250,000,
tax percentage is like 40 something
percent.
And then sales tax and all the other
taxes that you have to take,
any consideration,
state tax,
all this different stuff,
right?
Property tax,
I think about all the taxes you pay to
save up a million bucks get,
it's a lot of money.
So if he leaves out of that million
bucks to you,
you don't get the million dollars,
you have to be tax on that million
dollars.
So you have to be taxed on money.
He's already been taxed on.
It's not like he's,
unless he gives you a gold coins.
But even if he gives you gold coins,
you Oh,
the value of those gold coins in tax,
you owe a percentage in tax.
So let's say if I to sit rows,
I have a safe and every day I put a gold
coin in there.
I put money in the bank.
You got a half a mil in the bank or they
with thousands thousand savings.
But I probably got like 2 million back
thing coins and nobody knows what I
leaving cause Joe Rogan to pay taxes on
that.
Yes,
I would legit even if nobody would.
Well,
if otherwise it would,
it wouldn't be mine unless you'd written
it off to me.
Right.
So once you write it off to me,
then it becomes mine.
So if it becomes mine,
that's some money that someone just gave
me.
I got to pay tax on it.
Uncle Sam is just a robber just to like,
oh,
what'd you get a gift,
Joey?
You get a gift from me.
That's nice.
How come I didn't get a gift?
Where's my fucking gift?
But what if I want my fuck?
What the fuck?
What have Uncle Sam don't know about
that 2 million?
Would you rat?
Well,
you have to.
You have to figure out a way that you
have that 2 million.
See if someone gives it to you.
What does this gift tax.
Okay.
How's that work?
The following gifts are considered to be
taxable gifts when they exceed an annual
gift exclusion amount of $14,000 taxable
gifts count as part five point $3
million in 2014 you're allowed to give
away during your lifetime before you
must pay the gift tax.
Why hold the fuck on gifts subjects to
the d?
So if I give you something and it is
expensive,
you have to pay a gift tax.
It's over a certain amount of money.
That's disgusting.
Thousand Dollars.
It really is.
It's really sad.
That's just sad.
It's sad that we live in this fucking
country that thinks it's okay to steal
money like that from people.
Like say if you don't have anything and
you know you don't make a lot of money
and a guy gives you $20,000 you have to
give the government a piece of that
$20,000 fuck them.
Fuck them.
I mean fuck that.
That's bullshit.
What about when you like when I first
moved here,
it was my first like real adult job and
I figured out I was working in 30% of
the time for the government.
They take 30% yeah,
directly out of and it just,
it blew my mind.
And then,
and then like I don't know what's going
on with trump,
but like in the last election,
I think Mitt Romney finally came out
until he paid like something like 17%
which is not like they,
it's an,
it's,
it's so sad.
It's,
it frustrates people when like the rich
people can have all those deductions and
pay 17% oh yeah,
we're paying 30 well there's tax
shelters and then there's also storing
money overseas.
That's where thing gets things gear real
weird.
Cause there's a lot of super fucking
uber rich people that have a fuck load
of money stored overseas.
And by doing that and by these oh,
these overseas tax shelters,
they can fucking hide a lot of money.
You know who's got that going on?
I remember that dude who had those late
night commercials,
the weight loss secrets.
They don't want you to know about Kevin
Trudeau.
Remember that Kevin Trudeau guy?
Yeah.
That guy made a fucking grip of money
ripping people off and vanished and uh,
he went to jail,
he went to jail.
But the money vanished.
Like he just like,
there's a lot like he's claiming he
doesn't know where any of it is.
And so then they'll lock them up.
They're going to lock them up for like
10 years.
But then once he gets out,
that guy's going to get in the fucking
raft.
It's going to peddle out to the middle
of the ocean to get picked up by a yacht
and swept off to Costa Rica or wherever
the fuck he's got that money hidden like
these,
a lot of these reg really rich dudes,
they figure out a way to preserve as
much of that money as possible.
That's why they kind of like Bernie
Sanders comes along and they fucking
freak out.
He was shot him up,
shut him up the fuck is he saying he
wants more people to pay how much and
then there's like there's rates while he
was in favor of like say if you make a
certain amount of year,
like if you make more than $15 million a
year,
let's just make up a number then every
dollar over that they could tax you buy
like some stupid amount wasn't only 90%
percent.
Yeah.
And he said he didn't think that was too
much.
The idea is like you shouldn't be
winning the game that that much like if
the game is about money and the idea is
like well we should probably be control
how much money people make.
Cause it shouldn't be just about money,
should be about productivity,
how much you contribute.
It shouldn't be that you figure out how
to move numbers around and some
accounts.
And because of that you've made $3
billion.
Like what have you done?
What have you actually contributed to
society?
You figured out some weird little
loopholes and little sneaky ways you can
move ones and Zeros around on servers.
And because of that you've made $1
billion.
Like so his idea is that that shouldn't
be possible.
And that after,
you know,
it's not like you can't be rich,
but everything after like $15 million a
year,
you got to fucking just give it all
back.
But that people are not going to work
that hard.
They're going to get to that $15 million
a year mark and they got a slow it down,
a backing off,
just go on vacation.
Yeah.
And they're every,
well it slows productivity cause those
crazy fucks is dark as it is.
Like they have to be washed.
She's just gotta be some regulation
because greedy fucking people get
greedy.
But if you don't have their,
their ability to push it to the limit,
if they don't have that ability,
we'll have a lot less things that are
new,
a lot less innovation does be a lot
less.
Um,
the companies like huge companies like
apple and companies where you buy like
awesome shit,
it's going to be a lot less of them.
They just,
people are not going to push that hard
cause they did not going to get the
benefits that you like.
You get crazy benefits when you're some
Elon musk character.
You know when you've got billions and
billions of dollars.
He's a crazy benefit to that.
Not just a benefit in terms of like
being a guy who's like an innovator and
someone who makes cool shit.
But there's also benefits financially.
Like the guy lives in a castle,
right?
He can do whatever the fuck he wants.
He flies around in private jets.
If you're limiting people and living in
there,
the amount of money they can make that
drastically,
you're going to lose a lot of those
people.
It's not a good argument for a
going against
sort of organizing wealth to the point
where wealth distribution,
but it's a,
it's the reality of human nature.
You know,
people,
people aren't gonna work that hard if
they can't make a grip of money they
want to make.
But again,
I put a box of $2 million and I leave
with you.
I think at the fucking wake.
My wife cause you to my and then I have
to pay.
Would you have to,
why?
Because you go to jail.
How would you,
how would they find that?
They're going to find out because I have
$2 million all of a sudden.
No they're not.
What do I do with the money?
Just keep it in a bag.
No,
but you know,
you,
you money has like,
like they could find out,
but if they see is,
here's the thing,
if you,
if they found out you're going to jail,
you'd have to trust the person.
If you have $2 million,
listen,
if you have $2 million and you go to
jail,
you would give that $2 million back to
get out of jail.
You wouldn't know somebody who died and
left a million cash.
It was illegal type shady character in
their hands.
The money went to three different places
and now the sisters got it and she never
paid taxes.
She just came from Cuba.
She is spending a little bit here and
there.
If I gave you $2 million,
the first thing you'd do is go to the
Lee.
Lee's got a restaurant on Ventura
Boulevard.
Angelina's I don't know what he grosses
out of that.
When you go to the lead and you go,
I'm going to give you a hundred grand a
year,
you're going to pay me 60
I'm not going to show up to work.
You're going to pay me 60 grand a year
and get my money back and I'll pay taxes
on that stupid amount.
I didn't give him nobody a half a
million dollars that you left me.
That's an interesting way to do it.
To have like a no workshop you to pay
somebody.
You keep 40 why can't do it?
It's illegal.
40 grand.
Shut your fucking mouth til the day I
die.
So the day I died,
you got an extra 40 off me just for
doing the paperwork this month.
Well that would work if you could do it
this way to do it.
Somebody leaves me 2 million fucking
dollars.
That's not in the television industry.
This guy sold coke or whatever.
Here's the problem.
You're saying
Dick,
that person I saying Dick Dog,
that person has to figure out a way to
justify getting that money like that.
Where do you get that hundred thousand
dollars where'd that go?
Nobody knows.
Now listen,
there's tons of people that have done
shit.
You just said it you so listen.
You work hard for your money.
You're going to send money to some
fucking Bahamian.
Back with two fucking guys were weapon
is holding your money.
Good fucking luck.
Nobody sends over 50 mil unless they got
50 mil hidden over here.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't.
You see what happened to Johnny Depp in
that movie there with the coke?
When he went back down in the Panamanian
government took his fucking money.
It took $250 million from a little more
blow.
That happens all the time.
That happens all the fucking time.
They'll switch back accounts.
You trust somebody with your fucking $10
million over that.
Really for me to put $10 million,
12 hours from me,
I can have 10 million.
That was close by too.
That's gotta be so I know.
Thousand you know if,
if when they watched narcos,
those fucking Panamanians whenever they
were,
they making so much money.
They were burying that Colombians
burying it looked like it was seeds.
Yeah,
just plant the money tree.
They had to figure out where to put it.
What are they saying?
He spent 2,500 a month on rubber bands.
Four or something crazy.
You know how many millions of dollars?
20 how much money?
500 is what I saw on rubber bands at one
time.
He broke $1 million just to stay warm.
Jesus cried.
It was cold at night.
He just put money on the thing limit
just to stay warm.
I wonder what keeps a guy like that?
Here's a perfect example.
I mean not it's obviously drug dealing
and not capitalism,
but what keeps a guy pushing when he's
making that much money?
What keeps the guy from Virgin American
look,
keeps an American,
will keeps trump building and making
millions of things.
What is it?
Power,
right?
It's gotta be three of the seven.
Yeah.
You were speaking about addiction to
drama earlier.
It seems like.
What would be the same thing?
Get Your Dick sucked by that.
Listen,
that rats ate $1 billion of Pablo
Escobar's profits each year.
He was earning so much a year.
We would write off 10% of the money
because rats would eat it in storage or
be damaged by water or lost.
Holy Shit.
Cartel spent 25 yeah,
and rubber bands to hold the money
together.
Oh my God.
This is a crazy stats,
but the thing about Escobar's,
he made more money than you could ever
possibly spend and yet he kept working.
He kept wanting that money to come in.
He kept working and from the little I've
seen people loved him there.
Yeah.
Cause he would build soccer stadiums and
do all of them.
I think that's part of the reason why
people get annoyed with trump or whoever
you want to say here because it doesn't
seem like they're doing anything.
Well it's also that thing when you're
selling drugs you get locked up in a
business like Escobar was we had so much
power and so much drugs he was selling.
You don't want to give that power to
somebody else.
So once you've got that whole thing down
and you're making all that
money like do you,
you must be incredibly reluctant to give
that up.
I mean think about how long it took him
to to put together the network to make
the kind of money that he was making
towards the end.
Very reluctant to just hand that over to
somebody else because the business is
always going to be there that the demand
is always going to be there,
the supplies it was going to be there,
like who's making these transactions?
You just have to give it to somebody
else.
And then plus you'd open yourself up to
all these other fucking drug dealers
becoming just as crazy as you were when
you're coked up and nuts.
He,
I read it.
One of his books,
I read one of the books by a Colombian
journalists,
like I just don't read any off of.
This guy was referred to me like this
guy really worked in the transit.
He was an amazing
eye.
He couldn't read any CEO fucking 500
company and how it's them with a third
grade education.
What did he have?
He knew he knew what he had.
He knew the price.
He knew how to buy people off and he
knew how to speak like he was a fucking
Yanno like have you looked at them in
the street?
And I go,
that guy makes 6 million and out where
you'd go,
Joey.
Look,
it was a belt buckle was belt buckle was
got.
I got a belt buckle is big,
but the guy made so much money.
I knew a guy that was making 6 million
every six weeks,
6 million every six weeks because I know
him personally.
No,
but I knew him on site.
I knew what he did.
Was He doing?
He was,
what do you think he was doing?
He wasn't even looking at the code.
You understand me?
I wasn't even looking at,
it was coming from Columbia with Landon,
Denver and from then he would ship it to
no walkie Hawaii and all the states
around it.
Cause that what?
He shipped that drought,
white people with a family put in the
trunk of a car and we're going scan me
and why?
Why are you going skiing?
And you got 25 fucking pounds.
My the back of your truck.
You don't even see it.
You can just say you go somewhere,
you meet somebody handed off.
You don't even have him go home.
Just give him the car
like a movie.
It's like a giant time.
I'll just give him the car.
You see all this giant dip shit that's
going on in the news.
Johnny Depp is girl.
Doug Stan Hope wrote an article.
It's scary.
Yeah.
Well it's one of two things.
Either giant deb really beat up his
girlfriend or his girlfriend is lying
and saying that giant depth beat him up
and Stan hope and his girlfriend saw it
the whole time.
That Stan hopes version of it.
I trust Dan up.
I trust him very well.
I trust Dan hope,
but as much as anybody I know.
So if he says that,
that she was manipulating him and that
she was going to,
she had said and he had was worried that
she was going to do this.
Yeah.
Johnny Depp was being blackmailed by
amber heard.
Here's how I know guest column,
Doug's Dan hope the rap bunch of people
got upset at me for tweeting that it's
cause it's,
you're not supposed to take a side.
Uh,
and if you do take aside,
do you have to take the side because a
woman's
should could potentially be actually
getting abused.
Did he get arrested?
I don't think so.
The cops came and I think they found no
evidence of what happens when the cops
come and there's an argument now.
Yeah,
they take you away.
It's not good.
Yeah.
They take the man away.
No.
I'm also wasn't there.
He split the scene.
Did he?
Yeah,
he fled the scene.
But if there was a problem they'll come
and got it.
So with the pictures,
if there was pictures and shit's broken
now because of old Jay,
you have to,
especially in La.
Yeah,
it's specially in la,
but it's weird how many people like
automatically assumed that he was
beating her up.
It's um,
why is it that someone wants to pick a
side?
Is it like to show that you're a good
person and you side with the woman
always.
Is that what it is?
Like what's going on?
Like why,
why do people pretend that some people
aren't manipulative at some?
Some people are manipulative and we know
that,
right?
We know some people are going to be
live.
We know some people lie and we know some
people set people up.
We know some people,
black male,
we know that's real,
but why?
How come when it's a girl we all of a
sudden go away.
I can't think that way,
man.
I can't believe you're supporting a wife
beater.
Like,
what do you,
she knew that she had a scar.
She had a scar over her eyes.
She got a restraining order.
I just can't figure out why they didn't
arrest him.
Yeah,
maybe he's got recordings or something,
maybe know something,
but he definitely has a bunch of
witnesses saying that.
Uh,
Johnny Depp was worried about it before
it ever happened.
First of all,
Joe Rogan,
they live in a creepy,
creepy.
How so?
They don't live in a real life.
Joe Rogan,
I love Johnny Depp.
He's done some great movies,
but any of those actors at that level,
you just had a,
you just said,
uh,
you were talking about,
I just saw clip.
Well,
you told me personally about you went to
Naomi Campbell was party.
How is that different from your fucking
birthday body weight?
First of all,
I know you're 20 years.
I don't have birthday parties.
Birthday parties.
Okay.
That's number one.
Gives you the right,
you're looking at inviting like Thursday
night at seven cafe landwatch right.
You know,
bring a gift.
We're going to have dinner.
Listen,
I wouldn't go to your fucking birthday
party if you're born with fire crackers
out of your ass.
Cause that's not me.
That's not the world I'm from.
Once you 15 and you get roller skates,
birthdays are over,
you get a kiss and a blow job from your
wife.
I don't even give a fuck about a cake
anymore.
I do on the show.
Went to a birthday party.
Okay.
When you live in that realm,
we started him thinking,
what the fuck and Jayda Pinkett and that
black dude,
what's his name,
will smith if they lived in Philadelphia
with that son of this,
pick that motherfucker.
You've ever seen the pilot of empire?
No.
You didn't.
Pilot of empire.
It has something very interesting that
nobody caught in this country.
Nobody said done the pilot of empire,
the Black Dude,
uh,
turnstiles lonely with a pimp,
whatever.
This is seen in that with a young kid
that's gay.
Comes out with lady
shoes.
Huh?
And he's writing a lyric to a rap song
like,
yeah,
the,
he sees the kid,
he picks him up and he puts them in that
garbage can.
Did you know that?
No,
I didn't know that.
He runs in and they're like,
what'd you do when he goes,
fuck that motherfucker.
I ain't gonna have no faggots labored in
my fucking house and all this shit.
When I came from Cuba,
the first family I haven't counted
before the deal,
Lorenzo's was a black family.
They didn't say the word nigger in the
house.
This is the 70s and you couldn't even
talk about a gay relative.
That's why I always knew that gay guys
in the NFL and the NBA,
that shit ain't gonna work though.
That's just never going to work.
It's like a hidden thing.
But remember when they first introduced
the gay basketball player in the NBA,
people were jumping up for joy and not
those brothers.
Those brothers were on the phone with
the general manager going to listen.
This shit's deep rooted.
I don't want no game.
I was looking at my thing.
I don't care if he's black or not.
A lot of people can't say that in
public.
They would be,
people can't talk.
When we really liked anymore,
people just say shit just to fucking
sad.
We don't come from that fake worlds,
man.
We haven't been sucked into that
Hollywood world.
We won't allow it.
We just were having a Hollywood party.
What happened?
I don't leave to go to premieres.
I don't know.
I see people kissing cheeks twice
cause I need to be there.
So they come from a different world.
Joe Rogan,
what they see as reality and fucking
what's going on.
It's not really going on because they've
sucked up.
How many times you've been on the set
and what you're looking at is dog shit
and they laughing and giggling.
Laughing,
fake laughing.
That's not the world I came from.
The producer.
Fake laugh is that's a real thing.
We tell the,
I heard that they have to keep you up.
Build you up.
It's on the 30th take.
That was hilarious.
No ones.
I know what?
How about I come to your house and tell
you the same jokes?
Same joke word for word.
You're going to be giggling.
Nugget know don't,
don't do this to me.
Something that's too much.
So you got to assume these people are
living in this fucking world.
That God,
she was on the phone,
a friend and she calls her friends at
dot nine one one and all this shit.
You know who the fuck knows joe?
We right there.
We don't know.
He don't have a prenup.
60% he's going to lose.
Why do you get yourself in these
predicaments?
You fucking asshole picks up stabbing a
bitch and dropping off in the one seven
Johnny Depp have a prenup.
I supposedly doesn't.
California is a 60% state.
I don't,
wait a minute,
please tell me giant deb has a prenup.
Then you know he's on drugs.
If he didn't,
didn't have.
We'll find out here.
If he didn't have a Prenup,
he was on drugs.
Has there been anything before like I've
never heard of Johnny Depp headed girl
or no,
no.
His ex wife said it's preposterous.
It's not an Om.
Doug Stanhope so it's not,
I'm Doug Stan.
It was actually good friends with them.
He says the guys are like,
the last thing we would do is hit.
Somebody just doesn't have it in them.
It's not that guy.
It's not like an aggressive guy.
Well,
at the other hand,
something else happened.
His mother died a week before.
Now let's talk about a death.
A death takes a while to sink in,
but the first 25 days,
my friend,
you'll know.
Well,
Stan hope talked about it in the actual
interview.
Oh my God.
Pair did not have
15 months.
So heard benefits in California law,
which guarantees her a minimum of one
half of however much they're combined
worth increased during their 15 months
together.
Huh?
Forbes listed death as a 12th richest
act or 2015 and net worth of $400
million.
We'll see pirates of the Caribbean,
six seven eight nine oh my God.
During his badge to her.
Oh God.
Go back to her during,
he's managed to her depth.
God,
an estimated 61 million to appear in the
$170 million.
Alice through the looking glass and 40
million to star and black mass where he
won raves playing Boston gangster,
Whitey Bolger.
Holy fucking shit.
Oh my God.
You dumb motherfucker.
What are you do when you walk to the
bank with a $40 million check?
They don't even put you in the regular
wine with Stan hope so you don't go to a
bank.
It's all done wireless.
But when Stan hope was talking to him,
he was saying that his mother,
like obviously it troubled him badly
when he died,
but that this was as bad as that.
This was like looming over him.
He knew that he was going to get
blackmailed.
He knew that,
uh,
she was going after him.
She had some demands and then hit unless
he met him.
She said she was going to go to the,
the press.
He look man,
he's an older dude.
He's like 52.
She's young and hot and obviously if
it's,
if doug and Johnny Depp or telling the
truth,
she's been at plf live and some people
are really good actress,
man.
They're really good at pretending they
love you.
And when you're a guy who's like a
celebrity,
to the extent of Johnny Depp,
he hasn't been not famous for more than
30 years.
So through all that time he's had like
weird interactions with people where
he's not exactly sure where they're
coming from.
It's never balanced,
you know,
it's always,
he's Johnny Depp at the end of the day,
he's johnny deaf.
I'm saying it's a different head pro,
but the fact that he was willing to
marry her and not sign a prenup is
hilarious.
That's hilarious.
Called ether the ether Posey.
No little living in the ether.
The ether gel pussy like that non song.
Can you imagine if I came to you every
day and told you really?
In fact there's that and then there's a
pussy.
You're that Leora hace shifts.
You've seen how hot she,
oh,
she's beautiful.
She's stunning.
That's the ether.
That's the really thorough,
it's ethan,
both of them.
It's ether.
It's the whole borough.
You live in this fucking bubble.
You
know.
Everybody wants to come to la.
That that to be a star.
There's so much that comes with that
bubble.
She should have just taken a divorce.
Why should have to slap around to San,
I want to do this anymore.
That's all she says.
And she's making millions right.
Was only 15 months like so do you think
there's like a lot of hot girls,
especially in this town who their entire
plan is just to land a rich guy,
marry him for a year and then just leave
him?
No,
but let me tell you something.
If that girl was smart and she looked at
her attractiveness as a like a career
and marrying rich dudes.
Yeah,
there's like a lot of value and it being
broken up with Johnny Depp.
Like if she breaks up with him and she
makes like fucking look if he's worth
that much money,
she's getting 10 million,
right?
She's getting 10 million at least,
Yeah.
Right.
Okay.
So she gets a 10 million,
she relaxes and other rich dudes come in
and try to scoop her up.
Cause it's Johnny Depp's,
former ex wife or current ex wife.
You have to have a lot of those.
Like they,
they go from celebrity,
the celebrity,
if she wanted me to play and Kevin,
he went through a nasty bags.
If you want to get dark,
you just go to the next is to go to the
next Mick Jagger's wife.
Just married fucking somebody who's got
tons of cash and I said,
what's his name?
I don't know who did,
who did Jerry Hall just married like
she's 61 or something or 57 she's a
Rupert Murdoch.
Wait a minute.
Jerry Hall reggae.
Rupert.
I thought I'm Rupert Murdoch.
Kinda hot little Chinese boy
last week when you would hold on a
second.
Scroll up and it's 59 beautiful family.
Jerry Hall,
59 posts photo with her and a new
husband Rupert Murdoch.
85 surrounded by the children on their
wedding day.
Please expand that picture.
Much larger.
What kind of dark prostitution are we
looking at here?
This is dark.
This is like sorcery.
This is so strange when she can't even
possibly pretend that he's attractive.
That's like our dad man.
She was married to Mick Jagger and he
told her the wedding was Nolan boy cause
they got married on an island.
Shock.
Johnny Louie C for a guy like Rupert
Murdoch.
That's a prize.
He look,
he's got a bunch of Chinese kids.
Kids are like half Chinese.
That's the ex wife.
That's the last one he jettisoned.
She talked too much.
He didn't bow hard enough.
I still see your face when you bow.
No one.
Let's find out what happened.
Why am I tmz and uh,
Rupert Murdoch.
But he said he had some hot wife before
that Jerry Hall.
Good luck.
But my point was that I really think
that this lady,
if she just divorced him,
but I guess she wanted a lot of money.
She might've been greedy.
She might've been angry at him.
You know,
who knows?
I think it'd be more than 10 because it
was half of what they made in that year.
And they said he got paid 40 and 60 so
that's near 50 no,
it's half of what he is his money
increased by.
Okay,
so let's pull that up again so we get a
look at it.
I'm pretty sure that's what it says.
I think it said half of what it like,
say if he made $20 million one year and
then $30 million with her,
half of that 10 yeah.
You don't get a half of the fourth
amendment guarantees her a minimum of
one half of however much they're
combined.
Worth increased during their 15 months
together.
So she made $10 more that year and
Johnny made 50 million more.
Yeah,
it's madness,
man.
I mean,
she,
uh,
she got him.
There's a lot I've met girls like that
man there.
Coyotes,
they're strange.
They,
they stand outside your fence and they
howl and they're,
they're vicious man.
And there's this girl's like that and
there's guys like that,
right?
There's guys that are roofie a girl's
drink and raper.
There's guys that'll a rip a girl's bank
account off.
There's guys that are creepy fucks,
right?
Well,
there's girls that are creepy fucks to
does human beings.
It's suck.
And we have to be aware on both sides.
There's human beings that do devious
shit.
And uh,
just because a,
it's a girl,
it doesn't mean she's not going to do
stuff like that.
Believe me,
my friend was killed by a girl.
It's Phil Hartman was shot and it's
sleep by a woman.
They,
people are,
people are dark.
They do dark shit.
Men and women.
And the idea that you're going to go on
one side or another,
I retweet,
tweeted that article.
Not because I believe 100% that that's
what happened.
But because Doug's Tan helps my brother.
So if Doug Stan hope put something like
that out there,
I help him promote that.
I help other people read his work does,
it's not an endorsement,
but it's 100%.
Um,
I'm,
I will trust doug stand hopes,
opinion on things before I will take
some actress ladies word on what
happened.
I would to trust at least Doug's opinion
that Johnny was at least saying that he
was going to get black male.
But who knows.
He might admit smacking her yesterday.
Didn't want anybody to know.
I was like,
hm,
business.
I ain't bothering nobody.
I'm watching the baby.
It's four 30 that day.
About this week.
No,
I heard a knock on the door.
I'd never opened my door knocking on my
door.
You want,
if you don't call me,
I don't know when the door,
I just sit there once.
I'm one of those motherfuckers,
unless you call me coming over,
I don't open the door for anybody.
You can.
And that's,
I've been doing that for 30 years.
Nothing but the baby.
It was like daddy something.
It's just a dorm like God dammit.
Okay.
I opened the door,
three women at my door,
two of them a cockeyed.
I swear to God,
I'm not even trying to be funny.
Then from the Cert Church of Latter Day
saints.
Huh?
Okay.
How are you doing?
I go,
listen,
I'm not into this stuff,
but my wife is my wife,
isn't it?
The more minutes I just said that so I
could get off the hook.
I'm feeling the baby.
If you want to come back in 30 minutes
ago was I'm really thirsty.
Can I get a glass of water or a water
bottle?
Yeah,
man.
That's how they get you in.
That's a tactic.
I close the fucking door.
You know me?
I don't give a fuck.
Hold on one second.
I close the door.
My wife was
from Tennessee.
She saves those fucking bottles and
fills them up with water and takes him
to yoga.
I throw them away.
What are we white trash?
I throw these things away.
What's that done?
That done.
My wife saves him and puts them in the
freezer for headaches and shit.
So I went to get one of those and there
was no bottles,
so I give her a glass of water.
She takes off.
Now I'm running against the clock.
These three little more than bitches are
going to come back.
My wife walks in,
I go,
let me let me go outside and get it.
You know they stole my pipe.
When they asked me to get the water,
they stole my pot pipe from the balcony.
Nobody else was on that balcony,
but water got comes on that balcony and
he sees the pipe.
I don't leave weed up there.
I'm not that stupid.
I just leave the pipe with the cleaner,
the pipe,
the fucking,
my wife was there and warner came.
The lady who takes care of mercy,
they didn't steal the fucking,
the Mormon stole my pipe.
Let me tell you something.
I got in that car and a hundred those
few little cockeyed bitches down all
over.
I couldn't find them.
They never came back.
They stole my pot pipe.
Do you think they stole it because they
were just stealing things or do you
think they stole it because they didn't
want you to be engaging in such horrible
behavior?
Smoking marijuana while you're taking
care of your child?
I wasn't smoking when I was taking care
of the child.
I just always leave it out there.
It's always out.
That's how I mean.
I mean like you have one,
you have a child but he's still smoking
marijuana and like how dare you?
What are you doing with a pot pipe that
we need to take this from him?
Maybe they took it but they smoked half
ain't cockeyed know
that two bitches ain't cockeyed though.
Much shit that holes in her feet and the
shoes on.
What religion?
Since people knocking on doors,
I'm Memorial Day.
That's a guaranteed slam through the
door to the face.
Then you have another one that you kept
like he kept coming back.
I had a job with witness.
I was stringing him along.
I wanted to talk to you.
Caught me at a bad time to come back in
an hour and see him lurking in front of
my house.
I'd be dry,
could even go home.
I couldn't even go home.
I had to,
him was strung out for like four months
though.
Every time he'd come over,
you know what I really want to talk to
you?
Give me those pamphlets.
I ball in number.
So some people must be happy that they
come,
right?
They must get,
some people are like,
oh,
well I've been really curious about
this.
Please come on.
Any revenue,
invite anybody in,
you know,
in the hallways.
One time a girl was selling cookies.
It was pretty hot.
[inaudible] I invited around.
What happened?
Nothing close the deal.
Back then I was like 21 did you buy the
cookies?
I thanks.
So thinking about cookies,
I don't remember.
I just remember her being hot.
It's fucking ass.
But y'all didn't smells a lot of cookies
knocking on people's doors.
Speaking about taxing or what about
those religions that make you give like
10% church tithing on top of taxes?
Tithing.
Oh,
thank God.
We had a guy in fear factor,
they want 1 million bucks.
You don't really win 1 million bucks
because the government takes a big chunk
and most people they take the one time
payment instead of like the 50 grand a
year for the rest of your life,
that kind of thing.
Um,
but this guy before he did the stunt,
started talking in tongues.
He's like standing on us like cliff
side.
It's like Sha la La la La La
[inaudible].
They like,
they talk in a made up nonsense
language,
so like repeats the same sounds over and
over and over again.
But this talking in tongues,
he really believed it was like a
religious experience and that God helped
him win 1 million bucks.
I was going through a box of vhs was
about a month ago and I put one in and I
caught the beginning of the fear factor,
like one of the second season.
And I watched like 15 minutes of it.
And looking at it now and knowing you,
I don't know how the fuck you did that.
The show should have been,
how long does it take to Joe Rogan?
Fucks you up?
Like how long?
Remember when Tony Soprano,
I used to beat people up like there's
somebody would say something and he just
draw bottle and go over and start
kicking it.
Right.
He'd beat up Georgie like four times.
Hilarious.
He knocked the xy out.
That's what the episode should have been
like half the time.
Like in the mid sentence,
you just started punching somebody,
kicking them when they're on the phone.
What do you mean you don't want to eat
the fucking eggs?
That's the next level of fear factor.
Like go on there like with Chris liebing
as the host and every time he like act
up,
they just beat the fuck out of here.
Like America's ready for seat.
Fear factor was I had everything else in
it.
90% of the people were cool.
I think 90% of the time.
Yeah.
Yeah,
90% it was some goof.
He can tell you probably,
and I know you would look at him and go,
oh,
the cameras on as a grown man,
it's the closest I've ever been to a
street fight or that one that that one
guy in that persona.
And if that wasn't,
if that wasn't there,
if that was somewhere else,
instead of like in front of cameras,
I definitely want to strangle them 100%
like it just the whole thing.
It was like there was eight cameras
around all these people around and I was
like,
I don't want to commit to hurting this
guy,
but he's a dangerous fuck.
I'm like,
that guy could totally sucker punch me.
He just,
he was so amped up and kept coming into
my face,
kept running towards me.
I pushed him away,
ran towards me again.
I pushed him away and I was like,
okay,
this is on.
I'm like,
I'm not gonna.
I'm not going to pete pushing this guy
way.
I'm not going to take a chance.
It didn't doing something.
It's like clamped onto them.
I was thinking of key attended them or
needing them in the face trying to,
I was trying to think like,
I was like legally the good team would
be as much smarter move because I have
his head.
I'm definitely sure I get snap them
down.
I know he's got no defense and if I hit
him in the face it's probably going to
be ugly.
You know,
need someone in the face.
It's fucking devastating.
It's terrible.
It's terrible to do someone's face.
I got kneed in the face.
Ones broke my nose,
my eyes got black and blue.
I had a headache for three fucking days
after one knee,
one fucking knees straight on the nose,
just right on the nose.
That amped up that they want to fucking
physically fight you.
Like people show amped up.
They want to actually throw their
fucking limbs at you.
Boy,
everything's gotten so out the window
and when you're that close screaming at
each other,
like in each of the guys getting
in your face,
it's so close to like a catastrophic
injury.
Like anybody that's that nuts that's
screaming at you inches from your face.
Like all bets are off.
Like we're on a,
we're on safari rules here.
Like this is a,
we're in jungled territory.
This is a very dangerous time.
If it wasn't for a lot of people being
around particularly like if that happens
and you're alone manage,
if you're alone in the woods with a guy
who's screaming at you and getting in
your face like that,
like people die like that all the time.
People have a knife there in that sort
of a situation.
People stab people out of fear.
Just trying to be the one who doesn't
get stabbed,
you know,
you think it's gonna it's eventually
going to get ugly.
Oof.
I had a situation with Joe Rogan,
I was so scared,
but it made sense what people say that
when sometimes it takes to get hit and
the fee it goes away.
Like my ex wife got some guy with my ex
with her boyfriend to jump me one time
and they hit the dog with a two by four
and I think,
oh wow,
that,
that they hit a,
his name was Hercules'.
They hit him with a,
with a two by four and when I ran
downstairs,
the guy hit me with a two by four but he
didn't really break my ribs.
I just felt something and I could still
swinging and stuff and I was really
scared and my heart was pumping.
But after I got my hands on him and the
pain went away,
like I was a different fucking person.
Like his buddy hit me from behind and he
tripped and he started running once I
took the first guy down and I was scared
shitless and the one guy was way bigger
than me,
but I got so pissed off.
Which one ran the guy with the stick?
The bigger guy or the littler?
The little guy,
he hit me with the stick and I don't
know what I did.
I didn't know about singles and doubles.
I don't,
nothing about that.
I'm not going to want to know about it.
I was just so hot that I tackled him and
I kept punching and punching him,
punching a bunch of,
and then I got away and I started
kicking him
and I just started stepping on him.
I started stepping on them dog.
I didn't know what to do.
He was making weird noises and I went
inside the house and I called the bolder
copper was off duty.
Who was a cool guy and I was prepared to
go to jail like I had no.
I knew I had Nigga.
I was still outside on the ground.
Guy was on the ground.
I fucked him up.
I stepped on his ankle.
I fucked up his foot,
you know all that dirty shit.
I kicked him before I went to call.
I kicked him like three times in the
balls just to really keep him down.
Like I fucking kicked him with
everything I had because listen,
you want to hit me?
That's one thing.
They hit the fucking dog.
You ain't going to hit a dog in front of
me.
Not In your fucking worst situate,
especially in my dog.
You're not going to have my dog two by
four.
And the other guy took off,
and I know,
I forget the guy's name was durfee and
he came and he was 400 pounds durfee
big,
those big fat cops or boulder cop never
got out of his car.
And I said,
durfee,
you don't call the cops.
You know,
I protected myself.
I maybe went a little bit overboard,
you know,
and turfy goes,
call the cops.
This is beautiful.
Let's just wrap them up and dropping the
front of the hospital.
And I was always a pussy.
I was never scared that night.
Like at all.
I think once that,
that fucking two by four hit me,
whatever the fuck hit me in the side.
Well there's,
the anticipation of violence is almost
sometimes worse than the violence itself
because the anticipation that fight is
what everybody's terrified of.
It's like what could happen?
The unknown.
But once it's happening,
it's not the unknown anymore and it's
the bright.
What's,
what's going on,
what's going on right now?
Like in,
um,
competing.
Once a fight starts,
you don't feel the same fear.
Like the real fear is the way in
[inaudible] before the fight,
like the announcements,
walking to the,
to the ring,
waiting in the locker room,
all that.
That's the real fear.
When you're there and you're actually
fighting,
it's not a fear thing.
It's just a,
you're so zoned into the moment.
You're so reactive.
It's,
I would imagine that's probably the same
thing,
but that it's just like the fear of a
guy coming over and kicking your ass is
way worse than actually being in the
fight with the guys.
Especially if you know how to handle
yourself.
It's like now it's,
I actually control something.
Something's going on here.
I can react.
I can move around with something that's
actually going down.
Guys get addicted to that too.
Boy,
I'm very surprised.
I'm not really,
really violent.
Like I'm really surprised.
No,
no,
because they always blame shit on your
childhood.
They always attach things to your
childhood and I grew up around one of
the most violent people I haven't met in
my life.
That's why I know fear like I know what
fear is to be scared of somebody really
fucking great.
There's a difference between getting
smacked his Stepdad and his friends.
The people we hung out with and I'm
surprised I'm not more violent like I
don't,
I don't shoot animals.
Well,
you're smart guy.
You were well,
you would never do that.
You've always been an animal lover man,
but it's just weird that I didn't come
out with that.
Like I don't believe in a
stop though.
When did your violence stop because you
were still smacking people?
I don't know when,
Nah,
my violence stopped when I got beat up.
That's when that violin mentality,
when I realized that there's always
somebody out that's going to fuck you up
and now it's not like your mom.
It's not a controlled beating.
It's real.
Somebody could,
you don't know what makes somebody
punched you three times in the head and
stop.
Isn't that interesting how that is like
the answer that everybody always has to
how many pussies they're out there that
talk so much shit.
Like there's a lot of people running
around the really need to get a fucking
punch in the face and people go,
that is a terrible way to think about
that is awful way.
But no,
there's a humbling too that just like
that lady who was like,
thank you sir.
When she got fucked up by that elk,
you need to get,
thank you sir.
You,
you really need that in your life.
Like people need to get their fucking
ass kicked man.
They don't.
So they just run around thinking there's
no consequences to their actions.
The living in his nerfed
environment,
the guy like you,
you see some dark shit going on and you
know,
you know there's consequences.
You grew up with consequences,
heavy,
heavy going to the hospital believes
that's a consequence.
Unless you're always around drugs and
drug dealers and drug people and people
that are involved in illegal activity
where they have to protect their freedom
like drug dealers and being around drug
dealers like they're always one step
closer to violence than anybody else
around them.
They're always cause they are living a
dirty life.
They're living a life of complication
and and worry.
You always get to worry about someone
turning you in.
He always got to worry about someone
getting arrested.
Where'd you get these drugs from?
Oh where does he live?
And then boom,
you got to worry about people showing up
at your house.
You got a stash stuff in weird spots.
You got to always be on edge.
And once you add that drug to the mix,
like once you're dealing coke.
Okay.
Like okay,
take for example Pablo,
Pablo,
then snort cold.
He didn't do drugs but I find the movie
swung on a lot of weed.
Right.
Did you do any coke?
No show.
No.
That's all.
I think you're right.
Once you,
once you do coke as a dealer or heroin
or prescription pills,
that puts your judgment somewhere else.
When you do coke and you'd do coke for
three hours,
the high become something else that you
for.
It becomes paranoid,
right,
and the more you do it,
the paranoia,
it's shuts the window.
That euphoric state goes from three
hours to two hours to one hour to two
bumps,
like towards the FMA.
Two bumps.
I was done.
Paranoid was high on the way home.
If I was driving and I saw a cop car
over there just watching speeders that
cop cars stayed in my mind and grew like
a weed.
Why was he there?
Why that makes your trigger finger a lot
quicker?
That makes so many things a lot quicker.
Yeah.
I used to call the cops on myself.
That's not a junk,
that's not a fucking joke.
That's a joke on stage.
Where I originated from was in 1986 I
spent the weekend doing the best coconut
world and I kept calling the cops,
called the cops and they kept coming and
going,
what?
There's a paragraph in the other room
and the time they go,
can we talk to you
and said,
listen,
how many lines have you done?
And I haven't stopped him.
Like we suggest you put away the bag.
Oh,
that's so fun.
The next Monday I had a walkthrough the
police station,
like when I have to a good 12 hours
sleep.
And explained to them I wasn't doing
blow was just the reaction to the orange
juice.
And they're like,
listen,
you gotta stop.
You gotta stop doing powder.
You would call him the cops on yourself.
That God,
this happens all the time or period
asked me.
So David tape when I was a volunteer
fireman and aspirin?
No,
you didn't know about that?
No.
Okay.
Your uncle joy.
And,
and snowmass village to be,
you could go to a shitty gym or you go
to the snow mass club where they have
shaving cream and cute tips kitchen.
So you know,
Joe Angel in the snowmass club,
but it was three bills a month in 1982 I
couldn't afford Danny hundred a month.
Oh my God.
The snowmass club.
Oh,
the snowmass could even do what I spend
in those days.
The Aspen Club was what gray boy got
blown up.
That drug deals making 6 million every
six weeks.
They blew them up at the Aspen Club.
Jack,
right by,
uh,
blew him up,
boom up with a pipe bomb and then you
know who his wife May die.
Oh fuck.
You know,
he held down for six or seven hours.
He bled out of his ass that year was the
jeep that they put an extra plate under
the jeep.
He would always give somebody a 20 to
start his car.
This one night,
he didn't get my money.
He was 20 days from going on trial.
They found inside of this house in
garbage cans.
Well,
he would just go into a restaurant and
say,
hey joe,
how are you?
Joe?
Do me a favor.
He's on a thousand Tommy when it's over,
wait a second.
Wait on trades.
$18.
So he would just give them money and
that way he would never pay when he
would go there and just had a running
account.
Just had so much cash coming in.
That's actually pretty smart fabrics
where he would do so when he got blown
up,
you know who married his wife?
Who?
James Caan,
Mary Gray,
Bud's wife.
All those single why he was that get
money.
When they get blown up,
they fucking all getting remarried.
You're right.
That's why I'm thinking if she just kept
her mouth shut and it took some cash,
he'd probably give her many millions.
Right?
You would think so.
But how many more millions do you think
she'll get for lists and she'd have to
imagine some Iranian dude.
So person guy with the fucking Gold
Bentley was still dog.
They told me,
listen,
you don't want to pay the 300 you could
be on a volunteer fireman.
And I go,
fuck the 300 I'm a fireman.
So for six weeks they put me through a
training program where you just like put
out dumpsters and give them out of their
mouth and CPR and you gotta run with a
little bags.
I'm doing all this shit.
Coked up to the gills.
I'm selling coke.
I'm going back every week and getting a
pound of coke is selling it and to give
me my hobby.
I'm a volunteer fireman,
but have you ever been in Aspen
snowmass?
Yes.
I've been asked the only fucking fire,
so the one's white people don't know how
to do a fire in the fireplace.
Debit,
fire.
They scoop it and they put in the
garbage.
Then there's a fire blow,
so I would get coked up at night and
they'd be outside of my house beeping
behind pine with the bell.
It's like,
come on out,
there's a fire.
Come down.
Fuck you.
I wouldn't come out of the house.
I get so paranoid and then asked me the
next day.
What happened to you last night,
Dawg?
I took a sleeping pill.
I couldn't get up.
This must have happened because every
time I did show up it was always a
dumpster.
Right there was on fire.
What am I going to leave the house and
fight for fucking dumpster.
Eight white people with sticks and the
helmets were radios
over the fucking got a six third street.
They get in the mouth,
the mouth of the parrot,
the shit,
the fucking dumpster.
Did he do any fires and you're like
three fires,
but they would just dumpster fires.
So after a while I said,
well,
there's 80 years idiots with things,
you know,
make them believe that busy,
forget to leave me at home.
Call me for the big ones.
That's so fine.
There was never a big one,
so they fucking fine with me.
That's when they realized I was only in
it for the membership pass.
They said,
well that spends a weird place because
obviously there's a lot of router really
wealthy people and they've called it
home for a long time.
But then there was a lot of hippies and
moved there in the 70s because they just
wanted to get out of society and they
somehow or another gravitated towards
aspen.
Like I don't understand how that
happened.
Well,
what it was about Aspen,
Colorado jails and number one and two in
the country as far as capacity in the
old days,
10 to 20 years ago,
Boulder County jail was number two
county jail in the country.
They fed you that gave you clothes.
That's why they vote democratic.
They trim your toenails,
they give you rolling paper.
You know,
in boulder you could still smoke it.
Years ago they gave you rolling papers
and sick tobacco.
Real.
No other prison did that.
Everywhere else you got to pay for
cigarettes and Bogan and Aspen.
They don't even have a kitchen.
Paula France used to cater.
That's why fucking Bundy escape.
Paula French used to cater and ask him
if you're going to jail,
you get catered dentists.
They don't have a jail.
They have a county.
They killer Ted Bundy.
Escape from the aspirin jail.
Yeah.
Well you opened up a window and jumped
down.
Whoa.
And he killed the girl in snowmass
village.
Man,
that guy's scary.
He is a scary motherfucker.
He just escaped from the fucking ass in
jail.
Jumped out of a window.
Wow.
Well you got to drive.
Then you get to drive for a little bit
and we're in prison.
Like you went to Wiki spaces and I would
drive,
you know,
because I was the only one who went to
driver's license.
So they would let me drive to the places
where people usually go on the road and
see inmates picking up trash.
Yeah,
I would bring them lunch,
but at the same time,
those people,
they know where they're going the next
day.
So he called Joe Rogan and go,
Joe,
what are you doing tomorrow?
Nothing.
I'm going to be between a Laurel Canyon
and Compton.
Uh,
cold water.
Do me a favor by that sign that says
save the apples,
dumped the weed that and so that's what
you do.
So the invictus come pick it up and
things and they give me the bag and I
would drive with them.
The weed would be in the trunk and the
garbage.
So I believe the garbage on the trucks.
Then the Ebix come back.
I would mark the bag that they throw the
weeding and they would kick the weed out
or heroin or the fucking speed and give
me a cut while it's fucking amazing.
That's how they bring jail.
And he never got caught.
You know what's crazy thinking about it
now the gods are part of the action.
They don't want to get caught.
Yeah.
They'd rather not deal with the stuff.
They were extra income guy.
They'd rather just relax.
I get nervous bringing in an edible onto
a plane.
Shit edible on the planet.
My middle fucking damn doctor.
She joint disease and scared of the
edibles.
I'm playing the shit.
What's up baby?
That's it.
Three hours.
We did it all.
What do we got?
We got a July 8th you and me are
the car theater.
The MGM.
I was going to be fun.
UFC 200 yeah.
Yeah,
UFC 200 that's going to be chaos.
I think I'm going to go on Thursday for
the fucking thing.
I'm walking around.
Yeah,
for the expo.
Yeah.
Good idea at the nice people,
but you should probably get a set,
see if you can get a set at a the at mgm
club at Brad Gareth's club Thursday
night.
Yeah,
but you could do a show that there's an
iphone to fucking set.
You don't give a fuck.
Oh,
hang on.
All right.
That'd be through a seminar or some
learning seminar.
Yeah,
probably put some salmon has got some
great seminar.
I think that's part of a package.
Well,
this is a giant,
it's a giant week,
you know of the UFC experience down
there for UFC 200 so it's great.
I went about five,
four years ago.
The first year they did it,
you took me and I walked around.
It was pretty interesting.
Great stuff.
They usually have gotten grappling
tournaments.
I don't know if they haven't then this
time I'm sure they are.
They have a lot of Gnocchi,
grappling tournaments to seminars,
all kinds of shit.
Joe [inaudible] for me is to countdown
for UFC one 99 and you can watch the
church of what's happening now on
youtube and Vimeo and Vimeo and a,
you can get it on itunes.
It's a fucking hilarious.
I suggest you get on that shit and
subscribe a least at on twitter.
Lee's spell it out.
L.
E e s y.
A.
T.
T and of course,
bad flavor for young Joey Diaz.
And then Jamie Verna is still Jamie
Vernon when it should be young.
Jamie,
someone's got it.
I changed my a fucking piece of shit.
Name to young Jamie.
Oh,
beautiful.
That's all you need.
The display name.
That's all you need,
ladies and gentlemen.
Good night.
We'll be back tomorrow.
Sam Harris.
See you soon.
Bye Bye.
Okay.